What's up? What's up, guys? It's Friday, October 31st. Happy
Halloween. We're
We're back. We're back. We're back.
Big show lined up today. We've got all the the Darius arrest
stuff. Okay. Darius, yes, was arrested again last night. This
is a brand new state that he's arrested in now. Uh, very exciting.
Very exciting for us on the show. Okay. What a what a shocking
turn of events. Darius has been arrested.
Perhaps the most shocking thing of of all is the fact that possibly
he didn't actually deserve to be arrested this time. You know,
he often skates when he should be arrested. He often gets away,
but this time I'm not sure that he actually deserved it. I'm
not sure that he deserved to go to jail this one time.
Definitely deserve to get pulled over, though. Uh he got pulled
over in Oklahoma last night. I don't know the whole story, but
we'll we'll go through it. We'll figure it out. Okay, I've got
the clips. I've got some Discord logs. I've got all of the necessary
components to tell the story. What else do we have? Uh, James
Comey has officially filed to dismiss his case. We We're going
to read a New York Times article on that. Got a little got a
lot of little memes in here. Some Asmin techone stuff. XQC versus
Aspen Gold on Asmin Gold's position
for the
Apparently, America is for the whites according to Asmin Gold.
I didn't I didn't realize this. Nobody told me this. Got some
Erica Kirk and JD Vance memes. All right. Got some of those.
What else do we got here? Oh, the the UK the English Nick Fuentes.
Okay. Hugh Anthony got kicked out of his house by his parents
and he filed assault charges against his dad.
This is not really This guy is like possibly the most boring
white supremacist in existence, right? Possibly the most boring
one. And
honestly, this is the only way he could be entertaining is this
guy like lost his mind. He got in a fight with his parents. He
was reing at his parents and they kicked him out of the house.
Yeah, we watched this in the oiler call last night or the the
Patreon call last night. Yeah, it was uh it was pretty funny.
You will not win this war from from his dad. Was very funny.
Okay, we're probably going to check that out.
I think I I titled this JD Vance's griper problem. So, Fuentes
had a call out for JD Vance. There's this general
there's this general
mainstream GOP versus populism right now that's that's going
on. So there's like a mainstream GOP that tried to integrate
populism that tried to like dummy it down tried to to like subvert
it slightly. That's like sort of who's in power right now. Trump
and a bunch of his cronies who who you know they they signal
the nationalism. They are nationalists but it's like a little
different than an America first nationalism. It's got u obviously
they're incredibly pro-Israel and there's a lot of other things
going on there. So that that these two coalitions are are basically
going to war like officially. All right.
And I want to read a Richard Hanani article on that on what he
saw as the the possible alliance that's going to break that up.
And then
what I have I've got like the Ted Cruz kind of took a shot at
Nick. There's an old JD Vance quote about Nick Fuentes.
And then we got the Nick clip talking to JD Vance directly. So
we'll probably go through a bunch of that. We still have Sneo
versus Myron on the back burner. All the Techone legal case stuff's
on the back burner. All right, we've got all of these things.
We'll see what we can get through. Oh, and I'm probably going
to go through the Anakasparian versus Chank stuff if we can.
Um, a member of
a member of like this community a little bit, but mostly of other
communities. Teeny Tiny Tony, if you know this guy, he had an
interaction with Hutch recently on the doxing stuff. Apparently,
that was interesting. So, maybe maybe
we'll check that out, too. You guys didn't get to that stuff
last night.
No, Karaoko, we uh we had a short stream last night. We did a
long Patreon stream. I think we did three and a half, four hours
on Patreon last night. It was some good times. Covered a little
bit of Tactical Templar as well in that Patreon stream.
So, yeah, it was a very interesting time. [__] Tiska.
Yeah, it was a conversation with Taiska. Tyka is a very interesting
guy. Okay. Tao is very interesting. It's very funny. Checked
you guys were in there until like 3:00 a.m. Eastern. Yes, we
were. Yes, sir.
Yeah, Tao was having a great time.
Ty [clears throat] was getting told he was wrong by multiple
people. That's his best That's the best time for him in the whole
world.
All right,
so what do we got?
What do we got here? Let me just Oh, did I get this put in my
docket? I did. I did indeed. All right,
I'm just I'm closing up some windows here before we go into the
show
and we're good to go.
All right, I think let me check out the subreddit. Yeah, let's
check out the subreddit really quickly.
All right, there we go. We've got the first AI robot commercially
for sale and JD Vance calls out Hassan for abusing his dog. We
covered this through the lens of Hutch. >> So apparently
JD Vance >> Yeah, we covered we covered this [__]
We covered it. Uh, I do think people get really mad at Hassan
for being like, "Wait, you're about to cancel food stamps and
you're talking [__] about my dog." I do think there's
like a little bit of that that's true. I I also think JD Vance
didn't bring it up, so I don't have like that much. I just I
think everybody's fine here and people are just hurt for content,
so they're going to make something massive out of it, you know?
So, it is what it is.
Doesn't feel like that big a deal. I do think that like
it's totally valid to point out that JD Vance seemingly cares
way more about stupid online like culture issues than anything
else that he would be under his purview as the vice president.
Kind of
I think that's a valid point. Anyway,
what else do we got here? We've got the robot stuff. The first
AI robot commercially for sale. So, we started watching this
the other day. My name is Burn. Let's actually watch the whole
thing. This is a horrifying creation. Okay, this reminds me of
the Greenale human being. This is like
this is some terrifying.
>> And today we're launching >> hyper uncanny valley
>> humanoid thing >> for the whole >> Neo the
the robot. >> I legitimately thought this was satire when
I first when I watched this I was like this is satire
and obviously this is just fake and not real in any way. >> Let
you live with it. >> You're just now telling me what does
[laughter] it do? Like my chores, I I just leave and I come back
and they're all done. >> Are you kidding me? >> dude.
Tell me it's not real. Tell me that's not what this thing is.
It's literally the Greenale human being.
Like, yes, Chris Bletus, it is the Greenale human being one to
one. It actually is. It's horrifying. I saw it. I was like, "Oh,
yeah. It's the mascot from community. This is just a joke. They're
they're trying to make the dude the the community thing the whole
point of that mascot. It is the It's the most like horrifying
vaguely humanoid thing you could come up with. It's like it's
like actually just causes psychic terror to look at it and then
they made it into an actual commercial robot. >> Okay,
there's a lot of there's a lot of garbage going on. Let's get
to when he actually talks. This all started a decade ago working
really hard on making what is Neo a reality. But to me personally,
this started when I was like 10 years old. I grew up reading
these beautiful books and watching these beautiful sci-fi movies
where dude, if there's a villain that ends the world, he's going
to be Dutch.
Like 100%. Dutch or Dutch or Norwegian? One of the two. They
all have this like vaguely like
they they sound like they have Down syndrome all the time. Okay.
Norse or Dutch? Norse or Dutch? Not Finnish, but like Swedish,
Norwegian, or Dutch.
From one of these three places. The people who talk like this
all the time. The These people will Yeah. They They say the most
horrifying as if it's just true. As if it's just like a normal
thing.
It's It's [__] weird. >> The future was all
about how we as humans, we really focus on the things that matter
to us. You know, roasted the robot would be ensuring family had
time >> No, it won't be German. Miracle ter terrorist Marvin.
It will they they will not be German. I'm sorry. They won't be.
I understand Germanyy's where the threats have always come from.
And to some extent, I believe it won't be a it won't be like
a super villain if they're German. If it's Germany, it'll be
like the entire country of Germany, okay? It'll be the the chaos
manifest peoples, okay, of Germany
who go go out and destroy the world as a collective. But if it's
one person, Dutch 100%.
>> I accidentally unpin the message.
>> Explore the galaxy.
>> Know this thing's going to do dog work. It's like it's
always going to suck.
I feel like how infuriating would it be to drop 90k on this thing
and it just like misses every corner of your house vacuuming.
It like leaves spots everywhere where it wipes things down. 20k
I think. Okay. Even 20k.
I'm not even saying if it breaks anything like dropping your
TV. I'm telling you that like it's like supposed to clean or
do chores. There's no way it does this well. >> From a
hard question to a household task. With Neo's Autonomy, you can
get access to all of its latest AI features to get help with
tasks on demand. And the Neo app lets you interact with your
Neo from anywhere. But all you have to do to get started is turn
on your Neo and introduce yourself. >> Oh, wait. Hold on.
They're lying that it's autonomous. They already talked about
having Oh, is this like Oh, that's way better. That's actually
way smarter, isn't it? Hold on. Isn't that like way more intelligent?
We're actually just going to pay a bunch of Pakistani people
to to operate these things, to pilot these things.
No, India's India is too expensive. They're like going to Sri
Lanka or something. They're going to like Sri Lanka is not actually
the example, but they're going to like Africa and paying African
people to like actually pilot these things.
It's it's going to be like horrifying.
You're you're going to be paying for this thing. You're going
to ask it to do the most dumb mundane [__] and it's
going to be Wait, also the fact that somebody pilots it.
What prevents it from communicating to you somehow and you arranging
for it to do like things that it shouldn't be doing? Like how
do you know for a fact that this thing shouldn't be able to jerk
you off, but it's like, "Hey, I'll like send you some money if
you will jerk me off." like whatever your name is. You just like
type you tap out in Morse code whatever your like whatever your
PayPal is and then you jerk me off with the robot.
My I I feel like that's clearly the problem with piloted.
No, this will never work. I'm telling
I'm telling you it'll never work ever. This might Hold on. The
fact that it's like a piloted robot makes everything different
in like so many ways. one, it's like, "Oh, there's a human evaluating
the footage that's coming from it,
right?" Like, that's already immediately that there's a human
being that you're letting into your house to like evaluate this
footage.
That's already incredibly There's like actually this whole thing
this whole thing gets like weird and different, but economically
or at least Yeah, economically I can see why it's viable, right?
That you could just pay somebody, you have like a subscription
service, you get the robot in there, and somebody's like piloting
it around.
Hey, I'm Neo. I'm here to help around the house. What's your
name?
>> Nice to meet you, Harry. When you have a question or
want something done, just let me know. >> Okay, hold on.
Hold on. So, it was piloted for the demo, but they're selling
it. They want it to be autonomous in the future.
Okay. What evidence is there that'll ever be autonomous? I guess.
Are they trying to centralize the computing for it? Maybe this
could be like a usage for data centers for AI and stuff,
right? That you're going to do you have like the cameras for
this thing to pilot around and that like actually doing mass
scale video processing through these data centers is going to
make sense that this is like a huge huge usage use case for all
of these AI data AI data centers they're putting up. Interesting.
Like once they figure it out, I I it'll take a long time to figure
out, but once they figure it out,
>> we built the chores feature to give you your time back.
You give your Neo a list of chores. You schedule a time that
you want them done so that you can focus on what matters to you
while your Neo does the rest. You can schedule chores by either
talking to your Neo or using the app. The way it works is you
schedule a time that works best for you and then you create a
list of chores. Whether it's something more specific like watering
the plants on Tuesdays or something more general like tidying
the house, your Neil will get it done at the scheduled time.
If there are any chores that your Neo hasn't learned how to do
autonomously, you can use expert mode to have an expert from
1X supervise the session and provide corrective intervention
to help Neo complete any
>> anytime you're away from home and you want to see what
your Neo's up to, you can open the app and see directly from
Neo's point of view. >> Oh, plant dad, were you not here
earlier when we pointed out that it's clearly the Greenale human
being that this bot is? This bot, this robot is clearly just
like the most horrifying concept for like a amorphous humanoid
you could think of. Absolutely wild. Okay,
I let's say
I I have to be convinced. Okay, I have to be convinced really
badly. I don't think this is actually going to work. I think
something's going to be with this no matter what happens. But
have we watched enough? I kind of want to go top Ronson sent
me a meme. Okay, in keeping with the theme of the show. >> spear
pay. >> Oh, hold on. Reban donated $3 short vid of how
this rabbit will lead to I robot in stream chat.
>> Oh, Reben Rubin wants to share a meme as well. Okay,
Reuben Ruben meme in the stream chat. Let's check that out really
quickly. This is this is Reben Rubin's meme he put in stream
chat. Let's check it out.
One to one.
>> Can a robot write a symphony?
>> Can a robot turn a canvas into a beautiful masterpiece?
>> Thank you, Reuben. Reuben, thank you. I hope that was
worth the three. Thank you. Thank you, Reuben. Ruben.
Now, from one set of racism to the other.
Introducing the Shabbat, brought to you by Talmood Technologies.
No haggling on >> My name is Shmoolie, and today we're
launching Shabbat, our Jumanoid for the
>> Shabbat. Yeah. The new at home robot. >> You live
with a robot now? >> Yeah. I mean, now I can do my laundry
on the Sabbath. He does my taxes every quarter. I just go to
work and he takes care of all the schleing. Bobby, >> you
got to be kidding me.
Shabbat. Shabbat shalom.
>> Are you sure this is okay? >> Yes. [laughter]
>> Please proceed as you wish.
Uh you you wonder you wonder just how anti-Semitic somebody is
to make this and then you see that part and it's like okay that's
pretty crazy. >> Pre-order your Shabbat now. The world's
first athome Jumanoid. >> That's wild. Okay. That's wild.
I don't know. We need to we need to get you guys under control.
I I you you shouldn't feel as comfortable as you do sending me
these things. Okay. You really shouldn't. Here it is. Struggling
with the dishwasher.
From Joanna Stern's great video review of 1x Tech Neo of today,
she makes it clear it this isn't what's shipping in 2026. For
now, it's all remote operated and is still struggling a little
to do basic stuff. This isn't crapping on it. Just that this
stuff is hard. Okay,
dude. It's just trying to It's just trying to close the dishwasher.
It's just trying its best to close the Oh,
almost. Dude, this thing is it it still is like horrifying though.
Like there would be there would be if you have an elderly person
in your home, I feel like this thing's going to cause a stroke,
right? They're going to see this thing walking around in the
middle of the night doing some
actual stroke.
456 and it's not even closed. Nailed it. Nailed it.
Totally nailed it. Imagine this thing's light this thing lights
your house on fire when you were at work. I mean, you can see
it happening.
Almost certainly.
Jesus. Okay. All right.
Okay. All right.
Oh boy.
Yes. It was still being helped by the operator here. Yes. So,
little rough. Okay. We're through. We're through all of the
scientific horrors. Okay. I've got a couple quick clips I want
to do. I'll do one quick clip and then I'm going to read my Comey
article and then I'll go back to clips and then we'll move into
actual content. Okay. >> Thoughts on content? >> That's
the form we're going to take here. All right. Oh, I just saw
this random clip from Asmin Gold where he explains like why Tech's
an [__] and it's totally ridiculous in my opinion.
Oh, he also responded to Aerodite calling him out for the 30-year-old
women tweet and totally Oh, hold on. Hold on. Let's look at this.
Tectone. Tectone totally out on what he was saying. Okay. Wow.
Very cool. Weight loss. Weight loss journey. This guy's on. It's
this one right here. So, Erdite, I guess, quote tweets uh or
sorry, he tweets she tweets at him. What did he tweet? A fat
man in the gym is not going to make anyone of value laugh. It's
inspirational. We've all been there at one point. Keep going.
You got this.
Uh or perhaps it's your first step. It's never too late. Get
in shape. Fantastic. Also, do drugs to get in shape, okay? If
you can't do it yourself, do drugs. Just do drugs. Drugs are
the best.
And uh Erdite quote tweets that with his old picture making fun
of Pokemon and Valkyrie and or is it cutie and Valkyrie? I can't
remember. Valkyrie and someone. Okay.
And says, "Oh, it's cutie. It's Valkyrie and Cutie or Pokemon
and Cutie. I I can't remember what the company Valk and Cutie.
Okay. Uh, a 30-year-old woman having fun won't make anyone of
value ridicule her. It's inspirational. We've all been there
at one point. Convincing ourselves we are too old to chase a
dream or have fun, but it's all good. Enjoy yourself. Being 30
is not equal to joy. Play and fun is now prohibited for you.
Yeah. Unfortunately, I like agree with Arite, which is why I
basically tried to point out to Techone, tried to reply to that
one tweet and say, "Bro, you're like you got in shape at 30 because
of TRT or 31 or whatever the [__] 30 because of TRT."
And then you you're getting anime tattoos at 31. Like, what the
[__] are
How are you calling anybody else like too old for what they're
doing? And he responds, "It's a joke. These same people call
me bald and an abuser. I think they'll be okay." Have Cutie Cinderella
or Valkyrie called him bald or an abuser?
What? You're just like
I I don't I've never seen
I've never seen that. I guess maybe maybe Valkyrie or Cutie Cinderella
call him an abuser.
Uh it wouldn't be shocked for Valkyrie. You know, she's obviously
with the son. That might upset Tech. I just I don't get why.
Who? Where?
Can we see Can we see one of them doing it? Does anybody ask,
bro? Nobody believes you're joking. Everyone believes you are
half memeing at best. Also, stop Reddit spacing on
Uh, both things are okay.
Ray and Cutie called you an abuser and bald. Can't find anything
on them calling you that or even mentioning you mention or even
mentioning you at all. Yeah, that's what I would have thought.
He's He just totally
He's He's a total Oh, I I actually didn't mean it was just a
joke, guys. I I didn't mean it. It was just a joke.
It's just a It was just a joke. Don't get mad at me.
Good one, loser.
Anyway, back to this Aspen Gold thing where he tries to talk
about why Techton is aggressive with people. >> Thoughts
on content creators speaking out against Han uh or sorry, against
Techone, but not Misk and Hassan? I don't know who did that.
I have no idea.
Like, um I I feel like again,
Here's the truth, right? is that Teeone isn't really as aggro
as Mizkiff and Hassan's communities are. So if Tee doesn't want
people to attack him, >> why would you compare him to communities?
He has to attack people. That's what that's what you do. Like
if you want people to not attack you, you have to be a porcupine.
That's what it is. Because again,
>> did people go after Tekone anywhere near as much as
they do now when he didn't attack people when he's just mostly
staying in his own lane?
What the [__] is this? This is so stupid.
Nobody when Teto was just doing his gotcha games, even though
he was a complete in that space, people weren't going after him
broadly. He started injecting his opinions into the world, right?
He started just being Maine all the time, 24/7. And yeah, now
people attack him and point out his his hypocrisies.
And
like I this hasn't helped him at all.
This is the dumbest advice I've ever heard in my entire life.
I've I've never seen anything like this. Slime, you got to go
for a day, buddy. I hope you uh I hope you figure it out. The
reason why a lot of people don't go and do that No, I'm just
being honest, right? Like, I'm not saying you should do this,
but I'm saying that the reason why nobody wants to go and attack
Hassan's community.
>> Yeah, you you can't be doing that, okay? >> Or
Hassan or uh you know, Ms. KF. >> In fact, uh I I literally
have to restart Twitch. I'm not leaving that VOD up.
Uh give me a second. And I'll go restart Twitch and delete the
VOD. And
that's just insane. Don't Don't Fed post. It's totally
How hard is it? How hard is it to not be a like that? It's not.
Okay, restarting the Twitch stream now. Thanks. >> Reason
why a lot of people don't go and do that. No, I'm just being
honest, right? Like I'm not saying you should do this, but I'm
saying that the reason why nobody wants to go and attack Hassan's
community or Hassan or uh you know Msiz or or Destiny to an extent
uh is because their communities are so like aggressive and so
vicious, right?
Okay, you could say this, but I mean
a lot of the people Tekone doesn't like criticizing him right
now. A lot of them are not on Misk's side or Destiny's side or
even Hassan's side. This is just completely
Yeah. Okay. I will say some people don't go after those communities
because they could be aggressive, right?
But that's not the people Tone's actually upset about. Techn's
upset about people who make accurate criticisms of him and continue
to to watch his and laugh at him. That's who he's upset about.
That that applies to me. That applies to Queenman. That applies
to a whole bunch of other people. And that's who he's mad about.
It's not it's not like random. It's not like cutie Cinderella
or something actually. And
and I don't know what Asminagold's trying to do here other than
say like, "Hey, is this just him going, "Hey, Techton's community,
you guys need to go fight for him more. You guys actually need
to be way more aggressive." Is that what he's trying to do? >> So
if you want people to not attack you, you've got to build a community
like that. That's the way it works. And if you don't like that,
that's fine, but you can't tell me I'm wrong. And so Techone
doesn't really do that. >> Asmin Gold is totally right.
I can't think of anybody online who attacks Destiny or Msk or
Hassan. Oh, wait. They're actually the most attacked people on
the entire internet. And this is the most opinion we've heard
this guy spew in a hot second. Okay, it's been at least 24 hours
since he said something this stupid.
He literally just picked the most criticized people in all of
like Twitch streaming who have been Twitch streamers, I guess,
for some significant period of time.
[__] is he talking about? the only person he left
out was himself
>> out with people and because of that I think that um
you know people feel like it's okay to uh to dunk on him right
and uh music too loud uh yeah I'll turn him down sorry about
that and uh shield wall well it it's mainly about like basically
like for example like I mean we all know this this is what happened
with Lewig right as soon as Lewig or Charlie made anything critical
of Hassan people were calling them grifters you know etc right
and like if you have a community like that I mean it's a double-edged
sword because people also don't want to be around you because
they don't want to deal with it. But that's one of the reasons
why they don't get attacked as much is because um they they people
don't want to deal with the harassment especially like other
content creators, right? I'm sorry that's just not true. You
could say that that's what causes I guess some content creators
who are like mainstream not to criticize these people and that
would be valid. Okay, I do I do agree with that. Maybe maybe
it's not as dumb as I thought, but it's still like they're the
most criticized people on social media like at bar none or sorry
in this space like Msk
Hassan and Destiny and then Asmin Gold and maybe Tekon you could
almost add in there but it's because of their engagement.
You could say the other people don't get attacked because of
their communities, but I'd say Hassan gets attacked. Hassan has
the community. He gets attacked like way more than any of the
other guys. Dude, the color gauge was insane.
goofy guy. This Asmin goal guy, I saw this clip and I just don't
think this is the right thing. If you if you build a community
this way, if you build the community attacking people, you build
a community around attacking people, all of this, right? If you
do that, you're going to have obvious obviously you're going
to have struggles, like a bunch of struggles. It's going to be
major problems for you. You're going to get in fights with people
all the time. It is just going to be a constant consistent
I don't know.
Uh it doesn't matter how deserved it was. is dingling us, right?
Doesn't matter. But this is one of these things you always feel
the need to comment.
I'm going to say the most obvious thing right now. Let me type
in the chat.
Thank you. Appreciate it, buddy. Okay, hold on. We're going to
move to another Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold to Asmin Gold. Asmin Gold
to Asmin Gold. Okay, here we go. All right. What is with Why?
Now, I didn't see this clip when it first happened, but apparently
Asenold is arguing that like America is the white people's land.
I just thought that was interesting. I guess I I almost hope
it's clipchimped. I I hope it might be clip chipped. >> The
people they like they have to wherever they go. Like, is that
just like a like a epigenetic thing? Like, what the going on?
Everywhere you go, you got to be like, "Listen, this place is
racist, but not racist enough for my taste." Okay. You're the
foreigner. Like, Okay. Uh, so Hassan with the immediate racist
take. I think this is in white people's genetics. All right.
>> What are you talking about? >> Complaining about
foreigners is Japan is a foreigner is the most insane thing that
I can think of. I can't make this >> Since I'll say this
much, since the last time I've been in Japan, I've been This
is my third time now. >> I've seen a lot more white people
out >> Oh, for sure. >> And I don't like it. [laughter]
If you are a foreigner in Japan because you're white, then what
does that make every other person that's not white in America?
That's not the kind of identity politics you really want to play.
That's a bad way of doing things. The reason why there's a big
difference between people like Abroad in Japan and PewDiePie
versus somebody like Johnny Somali, the big difference is that
people like abroad in Japan or some of the people that come here
to the United States. I can't believe he didn't say Msk. How
do you not say Msk when you're in like drama with that guy and
Msk's doing back flips off of uh like cherry blossom trees and
everybody off?
Oh, you had the perfect opportunity to dunk a miz here. >> It's
actually the majority of legal immigrants that come here to the
United States come here and they assimilate into the culture
and they don't cause any problems. They're trying to just simply
exist inside of a different culture. And so that's it. America
is not white people's land. That's Europe. Well, it is. It is.
It absolutely is white people's land. We fought a war over it.
Duh. It got conquered. Like, yeah, there's a whole war over this.
Why do you think that the line is drawn in a certain way between
Texas and Mexico? How do you think Zimbabwe was was founded?
How do you think Afghanistan was founded? How do you think China?
>> I have to go back and listen. >> Majority of legal
immigrants that come here to the United States come here and
they assimilate into the culture and they don't cause any problems.
They're trying to just simply exist inside of a different culture.
And so that's it. America is not white people's land. That's
Europe. Well, it is.
It is. It absolutely is white people's land. We fought a war
over it.
Duh. It got conquered. Like, yeah, there's a whole war over this.
Why? >> No, he's he's almost certainly talking about one
of the like like the Trail of Tears or something. >> Do
you think that the line is drawn in a certain way between Texas
and Mexico? How do you think Zimbabwe was was founded? How do
you think Afghanistan was founded? How do you think China was
If you just want to say that America as it is was established
as a majority white place, if that's all he's trying to say here,
sure. That's >> the same way. Mongolia, like that's that's
the way it was every single
>> Okay. I mean, I don't I don't really
I don't care. People are going to go, "Oh, no, America was founded
like as a multicultural place." There there are lots of people,
lots of different people here. Um, I think it was founded ideologically
like with that idea that it would be a people it would be a people
like uh it would it would be like raceblind egalitarian democracy,
right? I think that's absolutely true,
but it was in fact like a white majority place. I don't Yeah.
Well, I don't think it was founded as a melting pot, right? Or
at least the melting pot meant something different, right? It
didn't mean people of different like um visual races. It meant
it meant something different.
Uh, but it wasn't multiculturalism at the start. I don't think
it's multiculturalism now.
I don't believe that America is strongly multicultural.
I live in Canada. Okay, this calling America multicultural is
a [__] joke. America is absolutely not multicultural
in any way. There's like maybe some issues of multiculturalism
or there's some remnants of some kind of multiculturalism in
major cities, right? You have like uh you have like enclaves
in in huge cities like you got Chinatown
um Little Italy like that. No, it's not Warp Thing. It's literally
not. It's literally not. You you you people don't even remotely
understand.
It's it's it's a total melting pot still. You don't have massive
Yeah. You you you guys are insane if you think you're multicultural
in any way.
Yes. The it's it's melting pot versus mosaic. Canada has sought
for a very long time to be a mosaic of cultures, right? It's
the entire idea of Quebec
existing within Canada, right? It's a different culture. It's
a different language, a different kind of uh like type of lifestyle.
It's it's very different. And Canada seeks to apparently, this
is the goal, let these cultures exist and not try to melt them
into one uniform Canadian culture. I don't think that's a good
idea, by the way. Yeah, I don't think that's a good idea. But
the US is like a melting pot. It's not even close to Canada in
any
Like people I remember how much people freaked out about the
Sharia law stuff.
Okay. Oh, looks like looks like Darius is um it looks like Darius
was released as well. So he's he's probably out. We we might
hear from him today. Yes. Yes. It was pure Elliot Trudeau who
brought multiculturalism who decided this was the way we're going
to go. I by the way I don't even like hate multiculturalism.
I think it's like a worthwhile experiment.
I think broadly long term it kind of won't work
right.
That's my personal opinion, but we'll see. I don't mind being
the country that tries it. Anyway, we uh we continue. So XQC
saw this clip and he decided to criticize. And I'm just very
excited to see what XQC's criticism is.
>> But wasn't only white people, right? And then the
>> Wait, what is he? >> White people's land. That's
>> Yeah, it was mostly white but wasn't only white people,
right? And
I Why is that a Why is that a useful thing to say? Oh, yeah.
It was white but it wasn't mostly white or sorry, it wasn't all
white. Yeah, it was it was like mostly white but it wasn't all
white. Okay.
I
Japan is mostly Japanese but not all
What are we doing? And then the vision morphs into a [clears throat]
mixed population and that's that's always going to be there.
You could be American
non-white and still your country. Like what the [__]
That's I don't believe that's what Asmin Gold is is saying here.
I mean I I don't take that to be what he's saying here. He's
saying in in a way that's intentionally provocative though, right?
Like I almost don't even want to talk about Asminold's point
there. I would almost rather have a meta conversation on how
Asminold's making that point to drive like controversy, right?
He's doing it's okay to be white. He's saying it's like an ethnically
majority white place and then he's going to pretend that that's
his position when he says it's like the the country like the
white people's land. He's going to say, "Yeah, well, it was like
ethnically majority white." Like, do you disagree with that?
Right? He's just doing the Mottton Bailey thing. It's not technically
like a true Mottton Bailey, but that's what he's doing. And he'll
never ever hold any of the other positions with calling it like
the land of white people or whatever, right? Yes. Yes. Turnup.
It's like I don't even want to engage cuz I I can see exactly
what he's doing. And so to just engage with what I think he means
is pointless because you have to point out that he's like rage
baiting intentionally with that phrase to get traction to get
a clip made so other people will argue with him and then he can
go, "Uh, well, I was just saying it was like majority white people
who founded it. it was mostly white and like uh white people,
you know, they built the culture and you know, if you assimilate
here, you're assimilating it into a white culture. That's all
I was saying. It's like, okay, but that's that's not normally
what people say when it's like this is the land for white people.
This is the white people's land.
That's not normally what they mean.
It was a response mimicking language.
it was it was like pointing out Hassan's thing and saying like
this is uh like another thing and I understand I think he believes
that even though he says you don't want it to go the other way,
right? He is because here's the thing. He's saying you don't
want it to go the other way. But he wasn't mimicking language.
He was saying if you do it the other way, this is obviously if
you're going to call it, you know, somebody's land that that's
the land for Japanese people, then this is white people's land,
right? I think he believes that if you're looking at it that
way, I don't think he's just mocking Hassan. I don't think that's
actually true,
right? He believes that he would he would stand on business on
that point. I don't think he would ever go, "Oh, no. I was just
mocking Hassan." I think he goes, "No, no, no. It's it's like
a white ethnic majority. It has been the entire time it's existed."
Yeah. >> Yeah. It was it was it was mostly white people.
But so what though? Even if it was most, saying that it's white
people's land is kind of odd because that creates a sentiment
that people that are white feel like they have more of a claim
to where they live at and they want to outcast people that aren't
white. And it's just odd. It's I'm sorry. It's odd. You can call
me W all you want. I don't give a [__] It it it creates
a a resistance.
Here, let's go back. Let's I'm going to watch this again cuz
I don't want to get it totally wrong. The impression I got was
he was saying if we applied that same lens is using, here's what
it would be in America. Cuz this is the reality of America, right?
>> What is with white people? They like they have to wherever
they go. Like is that just like a like an epigenetic thing? Like
what the going on? Every >> I would say Hassan is being
the most racist person here though. Obviously >> where
you go, you got to be like, "Listen, this place is racist, but
not racist enough for my taste." Okay, you're the foreigner.
Like what are you talking about? >> Complaining about foreigners
as Japan is a foreigner is the most insane thing that I can think
of. I can't make this [__] up. Since I I'll say this
much, since the last time I've been in Japan, I've been This
is my third time now. >> I've seen a lot more [__]
white people out here. >> Oh, for sure. And I don't like
it.
>> If you are a foreigner in Japan because you're white,
then what does that make every other person that's not white
in America? That's not the kind of identity
Ah, okay. I see. Hold on. I think I might have missed a little
piece here. So he's
politics you really want to play. That's a bad way of doing things.
The reason why there's a big difference between people like abroad
in Japan and PewDiePie versus somebody like Johnny Somali. The
big difference Oh, cuz he's conflating different groups here.
Like I think he's trying to say that if you reside there, if
you've immigrated there, you shouldn't be considered a foreigner,
right? Like you've immigrated there, you have Japanese citizenship
or something. Cuz I think PewDiePie has Japanese citizenship,
right? like he now lives in Japan permanently.
And so that's the comparison here is like PewDiePie is not not
Japanese.
He's saying that that person's like not a foreigner in the same
way and we shouldn't look at it that way. Now I will listen as
we go into the next part
There's not an there is not American ethnic. Well, that depends
on what you mean because obviously you could put the groups of
white people together in some way, right?
Like there could be some American ethnic that has existed.
Like I understand it's not a precise like Haplo group or something
in the same way, but it's essentially if you're looking at visual
minorities, right? Like if he if he wasn't saying, "Oh, it's
about ethnicity. It's about visual minority." Like you should
you be looked at as not a part of that country because you're
a visual minority. No.
Right. Yes. Exactly. Exactly. Evil Johnny Bravo. I was going
there before you even said it.
So, you could say that white isn't an ethnicity, but that's a
pointless thing because most people don't actually get a genetic
readout of you to judge you on your race or
right? That's like,
know how much racist PewDiePie must go through while living in
Japan has to be wild. Uh, no. He's an attractive white dude.
They win everywhere. I'm sorry. Pewdiepie does not deal with
racism in Japan or anywhere. Pewdiepie is like an attractive
white dude. He's an attractive white rich millionaire. Okay,
he does not he does not deal with racism anywhere. Everybody
loves him everywhere he goes. Okay, that's like I'm sorry. I
listen, I'm all for saying white people experience like bad things
and hey, it's okay to be white and all that. I'm all for like
making those points sometimes, but PewDiePie, I I have no empathy
for PewDiePie and the racism he faces anywhere cuz that guy's
life is literally the ideal for any person basically anywhere
on the planet. So, let's not pretend he's ever going to be a
victim. He is He is in the perfect position always. All right.
We don't have to We don't have to fake it here, guys. We're good.
Anyway,
okay. So, I see what he's doing here. I can I can give that charity.
I can go back and watch again and and give him that charity that
he's trying to say, "Okay, we shouldn't just say if you're not
in the visual uh the visible majority, you don't you're not automatically
a foreigner." >> People like Abroad in Japan and PewDiePie
versus somebody like Johnny Somali. The big difference is that
people like abroad in Japan or some of the people that come here
to the United States, actually the majority of legal immigrants
that come here to the United States come here and they assimilate
into the culture and they don't
uh most racism in Asia is towards other Asians.
Sure. Do you think most people in Asia can tell from very obvious
clues from very obvious context clues that somebody else is not
in the ethnic majority of a given country when they're being
racist?
Or do you think they're just like saying I I hate do you think
do you think when you go to Asia that they see Asians the same
way white people do in America where it's like oh you all look
the same or do you think they can tell each other apart and they're
like visible minorities in each other's countries? Cuz I I know
it's definitely the second
It's not It's not like different. It's the same thing. They just
don't have The reason you use that as an example, or at least
the way it seems. The way you use that as an example is like,
"Oh, uh, all Asians look alike and they're racist to each other."
That's like an insane that's an insane thing to say. Or maybe
I'm taking you out of context, but that seems like an insane
thing to say for me. Don't cause any problems. They're trying
to just simply exist inside of a different culture. And so that's
it. America is not white people's land. That's Europe. Whoa.
It is. It is. It absolutely is white people's land. We fought
a war over it.
Duh. It got conquered. Like, yeah, there's a whole war over this.
Why do you think that the line is drawn in a certain way between
Texas and Mexico? How do you think Zimbabwe was was founded?
How do you think Afghanist?
>> What? Who did they lose the Civil War to? Yes, but white
people.
It's still a white majority country. Yeah. I don't think, sorry,
this is not a question of like, oh, are black people people?
you should treat everybody like people. You shouldn't have slaves,
black people should have the same rights as anyone else when
they're in the country. But it's like not a black it's like not
quite the same. I will say though that I do believe when the
civil war was won that I do think there was an emphasis on hey
if you have been in this country for a long period of time you're
a part of this country. Asold's making that point. Asmin Gold's
point is you shouldn't look at somebody who's not in the visible
majority and say they're not a part of that country. That is
the point he's >> Okay. But I'm saying the white people
who won wanted black people that were slaves to be freed and
have land.
>> That they are this country as well. >> I fully
believe as much as he's a total I fully believe Asmin Gold also
wants black people to have rights and he's not arguing that it's
like not a country for black people. >> Well, I'm going
to need people like him to stop saying white.
>> He's hyperfocused on white. So, no, that doesn't come
across. >> Well, he's doing the Hassan thing. He's doing
Hassan is like off about white people living in Japan, right?
Yeah. >> And he's saying if you're not in the visible majority,
you shouldn't be considered a foreigner just because you're in
that country. You should probably be considered that based on
you being someone who doesn't um go and adhere to the cultural
norms of that place. If you're going and you refuse to go and
be a part of the cultural norms of that place, you're like acting
like a foreigner. You're acting like a loser. Like melt into
the society is Asmin's point of view. That's what that's what
he's trying to say. And I think I understand but he that's why
I don't want to address it directly because he knows what he's
doing. Okay, that's why the metapoint is incredibly important.
That's why it's incredibly important. Okay, because he is trying
to say something that makes sense
in a way that will get people to fight with him like in a way
that is offensive so that he can fall back. And I refuse to fall
for like the M and Bailey here again. All right. >> Okay.
Okay. I think I think he's trying to do something where he can
fall back to a different argument. Yeah, I think that's what
he's trying to do.
And hold on. Porter Beller wants to continue to make the point
um that Japan is an incredibly homogeneous society. So doing
the comparison doesn't make any sense.
I don't know if that matters. There would have been a point where
the same thing would have applied to America and the same principle
would have applied anyway, right? where America would have been
I think America would have been like insanely white at one point
at least majority visually ethnically white.
>> Well, America is >> not ethically homogeneous.
This is where's like the collectivist versus right America was
founded on the idea that they don't want to be >> uh ruled
and all forced to be like the same. They wanted religious freedom
uh
and and just like that, right? So, how do you have a
How do you subscribe to a majority
if your if your country's culture is supposed to be open to a
diversity of
>> So, he's not saying that. He's saying that if you're
going to apply this lens of being annoyed that there are different
ethnicities in Japan, then you wouldn't like to live in a world
where we do that because >> I'm done talking. I hate you
guys when you act like I can't be heard right here. My headphones
are in. >> Okay. Um it's just it's Yeah.
>> Okay. All right. Good one, Ginger. It's all your fault.
Okay. Um Well, she's she's gone now. I It's not a big deal. I'll
I'll fix the mic at some point. It's not a mic. It's literally
a directional mic. That's the whole point,
What did she say? She was saying that America is founded as a
culture that's meant to be like a melting pot that takes people
from different cultures, different religions, and allows them
all to exist under the same framework, under a certain core of
values.
But again, I think I think Asagold would probably just say I
agree with that. And he's like trying to bait people with the
white nation thing.
>> Stop giving my take. Stop asking about me, chat. Rope.
>> That's that's you specifically, Ginger, just so you
know.
And wait, hold on. and uh XNORMY. Both of them. Both of you guys.
Okay. Um we're almost done. >> They got conquered. Like,
yeah, there's a whole war over this. Why do you think that the
line is drawn in a certain way between Texas and Mexico? How
do you think Zimbabwe was was founded? How do you think Afghanistan
was founded? How do you think China was founded? That's the same
way. Mongolia, like that's that's the way it was every single
place. Oh, okay. All right. I I truly believe he's just trying
to rage bait with the white country thing in a lot of ways.
Uh and piggyback off of Assad, I I think the unfortunate thing
here is the person who's who's the person who's actually being
racist here is Hassan. In fact, uh it's just actually like inherent
in the in the Euro in the Euro DNA. All right. In the white in
the white Anglo DNA to be racist, to want other places to be
racist, too.
I I think Hassan should actually be getting cooked a little bit
more than Asminold is for this, which is kind of funny. Little
funny. Little funny. How is Hassan being racist when is Clipchimp
2? Okay, Vin,
if I tell you that black, like unless he's just going to go,
"Haha, just kidding. That racist thing I just said. Just kidding.
That's not true." Which he's allowed to do, but that's not really
the way he operates, right? Unless he brain, unless you want
to argue for me why Hassan is suggesting that it's inherent in
certain people's and erases genetics. okay to act certain ways.
I want you to tell me how that's not in it in and of itself in
fact racist and why we would have to go and find the context
for that
cuz I I just don't know.
That seems like you reflexively said it's clipchimp without thinking
about it at all and you're like, "No, no, no, no. It's just clip
chimp, guys. Maybe it is." Hassan doesn't believe racism against
white people is possible anyway. Yeah, well Hassan's for that.
Okay, Vane, go find the time stamp instead of wish casting that
Hassan's not being racist. Go find the time stamp, bro.
No, he doesn't have to come to Discord. He can literally just
find the time stamp.
Okay,
where are we going? I Hold on a second. I can hear that. Are
we
Okay. Okay. Going on to Erica Kirk and JD Vance. I think we're
done with this unless Fain finds a time stamp, right? Okay. Erica
and JD Vance. I've seen a lot of comments about >> Erica
Kirk and JD Vance and and it's uh it's getting a little ridiculous.
Okay. >> Blessed and honored
tonight to be able to introduce to you a very very dear friend
and his wife. They are incredible. And I see
no one will ever replace my husband.
No.
But I do see some similarities of my husband in JD
>> and Vice President JD Vance. I do.
>> And that's why I am so
>> to be able to introduce him tonight. He's an amazing
man. So, please help me welcome to the stage Vice President JD
>> I am. >> Now, that cuts at the least opportune
moment. Okay. I believe that cuts at the least opportune moment.
Hold on a second. Let me find the the rest of that. Where is
it? Where is it? Where is it? It's right here. I think I think
this is still
president of the United States
in Oxford, Mississippi. >> He like hugs her
>> night. His >> for some reason. She's wearing like
these leather these skintight leather pants.
We get this look here up from her. JD Vance looking like a goober.
Okay. All right. appearance comes and of the United States took
the stage in Oxford, Miss Mississippi tonight. His appearance
comes
>> Oh, I I Hold on. Hold on. It doesn't
rolling that backwards is not great. It's not a great look, is
it? Rolling that backwards. That's uh that's
Yeah. Yeah, he's getting her close.
Uh my favorite comment from this, okay, was this one. It's right.
It's the first reply. Erica Kirk wore those pants on purpose
to remind remind JD of his favorite leather couch. Good times.
Good times.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I know. Okay. Sweatpants freedom hit it as
well. Yes. This is the joke. Uh, it's being run. It's being run
to the ground already apparently, but it's still good. All right.
Running the fingers through his hair is wild. Hold on. >> 10.
The vice president of the United States took the stage in Oxford,
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Dude. Dude, he's like I feel like
he here is like, "Bro,
[__] my wife is watching this. [__] my
wife is watching this. What are you What the [__]
are you doing? Are you
[__] My
She" She's like still staring as she backs away. And he's like,
"Oh, I'm going to pretend. No, nothing's going on here. Nothing's
going on here. This is not real." >> Turning point USA
makes
it >> [__] My wife is watching this.
The [__] are you doing? Is that a victory >> American
comeback tours [laughter]
as turning that dog. >> Yeah. Are you guys Are you Are
you not entertained? It's the Maximus pose. Okay. Are you not
entertained?
God damn. JD JD's winning. Okay, you guys are going to get tired
about how of how much we're winning. Does JD divorce his wife
and marry Erica, then go for the presidency after Trump in this
timeline? Um, no. He doesn't, dude. No. JD Vance.
JD Vance is not divorcing his wife.
these are memes. JD Vance loves his
These are memes. I'll just say they're memes. Okay. Uh Erica
Kirk might be in love with him and obsessed with him. He loves
his wife. He's taken a lot of heat for having a wife with a different
religion, different ethnicity, right? He's not He's not giving
up now when he already got to the vice presidency. Does he though?
He does. He does. He did look uncomfortable. He did look >> Oxford,
Mississippi
>> He made eye contact. He looked away
Although that [laughter]
hold on. Oh, they know. They know. They know. Everyone knows.
Okay.
>> As Turning Point USA.
>> Okay. That's the final that's the final meme on that
front. Okay. Final meme.
Let's uh let's check out the Comey the Comey thing.
All right. Comey attacks perjury and obstruction charges in new
motions. So, this is up an update on the Comey the totally baseless
lawsuit from the government against James Comey. Okay. Quick
update on this and then I think we go into the rest of the content
for the evening. I'm not sure if we might finish up Cutie Cinderella
to start off with because I think there's just a couple things
there I wanted to finish up and then after that we'll see. We'll
see what happens.
let's read this and then we probably move into QD. I I'm not
totally sure. There's a lot of stuff to do tonight. All right,
guys. If you like the content, go ahead, follow on every platform.
Join the Discord.
All right. If you really like the content, you can throw a couple
bucks my way. You can super chat. All right. Via the the TTS
options, the Kickbot link, the Streamlabs link. You can sub on
Kick or Twitch. You can throw me a Twitch primer. All right.
Twitch.tv/jstlk TV
You can give kicks, you can give bits. All right. And last but
not least, there's the Patreon. patreon.com/jstk.
All right. We've been doing a couple different calls the past
few nights. I think what we're going to do is we might start
doing um
we'll have to mix in oiler calls as well specifically, but I
think last night was a supporter call, guys. If you sign up for
the Patreon Oh, hold on. Wait, what
do Oh, do I have my own? Do I have a Oh, I have a membership
now as a Okay, whatever. I wanted to view as a member. What are
the tiers about? What are the tiers? Can I not? I should be able
to go here and it should show me the tiers.
What the heck? I can't see all the tiers. Anyway, it's fine.
There's multiple tiers. $5 and up. You can get into extra content
after the stream. Okay. You do become an individualist if you
join the Patreon. All right. Thank you. Only mute. This is very
true. had a long call last night. Bunch of bunch of talk. We
went through some of the tactical templar stuff. I think we went
through what else did we go through? Oh, the Hugh Anthony stuff.
Queen was in there. He showed that to me and the rest of the
the the group there. So, it was good stuff. I just ate 18 Reese's
cups
and your name is Maniac. Okay.
All right. That has a certain swag to it. I got you.
Anyway, guys, that's the that's all the shilling for now. We
need Oh, we should probably need like 11 subs to get another
two hours on the stream. Let me see here.
Yeah, 11 subs, I think, is the number we're looking to get to.
Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. Anyway, let's continue. All right. Comey
attacks, perjury, and obstruction charges, and new motions. The
court filings added to legal challenges that James B. Comey's
defense team has already raised against the indictment.
Lawyers for James B. Comey, the former FBI director, sought on
Thursday to dismiss the perjury and obstruction charges against
him, accu or arguing that federal prosecutors botched the indictment
by misusing the grand jury process and by accusing him of telling
a lie that he never actually told. The motions filed in federal
district court in the federal district court, sorry, in federal
district court in Alexandria, Virginia, added to the popoly of
legal challenges that Mr. Comey's defense team has already raised
against the indictment. Mr. Comey, who has long been a critic
of President Trump, was charged last month under extraordinary
circumstances after Mr. Trump ousted the career US attorney who
was reluctant to file a criminal case and installed an inexperienced
loyalist in his place. This is Oh, what is this? What is this
dumb person's name?
Why did I lose I lost the name. Lindseay Halligan. Thank you.
Thank you. New York Times. Last week in their opening round of
legal briefs, the lawyers argued that the Trump administration
had brought the charges as an act of vindictive retribution and
also contested the appointment of the handpicked prosecutor Lindseay
Haligan, who secured the indictment on her fourth day on the
job. The new filings gave Judge Michael S. Nachmanov,
who is overseeing the case, two additional reasons to throw out
the charges, both of them related to the legal viability of the
indictment. the lawyers who asked Judge Nov to force the government
to provide them with what is known as a bill of particulars,
a document that would add details to the barebones charges Mr.
Comey is facing, and describe with more specificity how prosecutors
believe he broke the law. The two-page indictment accuses Mr.
Comey of lying to the to lying to and obstructing Congress during
a hearing before the Senate Judiciary Committee on September
30th, 2020 that delved into his handling of the so-called Crossfire
Hurricane investigation, which scrutinized ties between Russia
and Mr. Trump's 2016 presidential challenge or presidential campaign.
Mr. Comey testifying by video conference during a Senate hearing
in September 2020.
At at the hearing, Senator Ted Cruz, Republican of Texas, asked
Mr. Comey whether he had authorized anyone at the FBI to be an
anonymous source in the in news reports. The indictment says
that Mr. Comey misled the committee by saying that he had not
done so. In one of their motions, Mr. Comey's lawyers attacked
the very substance of those allegations, saying that Senator
Cruz's questions were fundamentally ambiguous and that Mr. Comey's
response to them was literally true and so could not form the
basis of a perjury charge. Yes, we've we've already looked into
this that essentially when he said, "I didn't do this," he was
telling the truth because what they say is the lie is that there
was somebody authorized to go to the media with leaks from the
Justice Department, but that happened under Andy McCabe, one
of Mr. Comey's deputies. And Andy McCabe testified that James
Comey was unaware. So there is no testimony from anyone that
James Comey was aware. There's only testimony that he was unaware
and was informed after the fact. So in fact, you can't possibly
accuse him of knowing and setting this up, right? When when you
have no testimony indicating he lied in any way.
James Comey wasn't arguing that there were no leaks that happened.
He was saying he didn't authorize those leaks, which was true.
Okay, Mr. Cruz's questions. And they didn't not know the leaks
happened. They already knew the leaks had happened.
So Mr. Cruz's questions, the lawyers argued, suggested that he
was asking about whether Mr. Comey had authorized Andrew McCabe,
who had once served as his deputy at the FBI, to leak information
to the news media. Prosecutors have since clarified that they
believe Mr. Comey lied about a different FBI different former
FBI employee altogether, Daniel C. Richmond. Moreover, the lawyer
said Mr. Comey's answer to Mr. Cruz was not a detailed direct
response, but was instead a tur reply in which he said he stood
by previous testimony he had given 3 years earlier when he was
asked similar questions in a different congressional hearing
that his lawyers wrote was literally a true statement regardless
of whether the prior testimony was itself truthful.
Oh, so he's saying basically that you cannot say
that he's lying.
So there's like two things. one, it was truthful. And even if
it wasn't truthful, you can't use his reference to it as a lie.
He says he would stand by his statements then. Just because he
might have been wrong or or even lied back then doesn't mean
that now that's a
right? So a little bit of lawyering going on there. Not exactly
how I'd look at it, but in their second motion, oh sorry,
uh they added fundamental to any false statement charge are both
clear questions and false answers. Neither exists here. In their
second motion, the lawyers homeed homeed in on Miss Halligan
herself, a former personal lawyer to Mr. Trump, who is handling
her first criminal case when she appeared in front of the grand
jury seeking to indict Mr. Comey. Miss Halligan, they added,
is a former insurance lawyer who lacks any prosecutorial experience.
Substantively, the lawyers accused Miss Halligan of committing
irregularities so severe and pervasive in front of the grand
jury that they likely prejudiced the grand juror's narrow decision
to indict. They reminded Judge Nachmanov of some of her rookie
errors, pointing out how she kept the grand jurors in the courthouse
well past normal business hours after they failed to endorse
one of the three original counts she was seeking. The lawyers
also noted that Miss Haligan had confusingly signed two different
versions of the indictment.
Lindsay Hallanigan, appointed by President Trump to be interim
US attorney in the Eastern District of Virginia, has never prosecuted
a single case in her career before securing the indictment of
James Comey.
As further evidence that the grand jury process was was potentially
tainted, the lawyers said that the FBI agents who testified to
grand jurors might have improperly shared privileged communications
between Mr. Comey and one of his lawyers. All available information
regarding Miss Halligan's first ever grand jury presentation
smacks of irregularity. The lawyers wrote, "It is virtually unheard
of for a brand new prosecutor to make her first grand jury presentation
alone without the supervision and guidance of an experienced
prosecutor to ensure the absence of factual and legal errors.
The prosecutors handling the case, both of whom were brought
in North Carolina after Miss Halligan was unable to find anyone
in the Eastern District of Virginia to do the job, are scheduled
to respond to the defense's motions over the next two weeks.
A hearing has been set for November 13th to consider the challenge
to Miss Halligan's appointment. It will be heard by visiting
by a visiting judge from South Carolina, Cameron McGowan Curry,
who has agreed to combine Mr. Comey's attack on the appointment
with that from m another Trump adversary charged by Miss Halligan,
Leticia James, the New York Attorney General. So apparently both
Comey and Leticia James have challenged this appointment overall
and that the same judge will hear both of those challenges, saying
that she was only she was only appointed as like a hatchet man,
which obviously is true. So I do think it's like interesting
to see how this will turn out.
The hubris of these manga stooges must be studied. I mean, I
don't know what's going on with Lindsay Halligan.
We obviously read the Oh, what what was it called? The
what was it? I I forget the article we read, but it was from
the journalist who Lindsay Haligan texted. Lindsay Hallagan was
texting a journalist saying, "Hey, you're getting things wrong."
And then kind of leaking some details she probably shouldn't
have, and she's not even supposed to talk about any of the cases
under her purview at all. It's like actually improper for her
to reference these cases essentially ever. It's like against
norms of the of the Justice Department.
Yeah. So anyway, I'm I'm expecting this will give us a good idea
because if if the world is just, if it's possibly just. Okay.
Wait, what is mature mode? Porter Beller, stop turning random
[__]
Don't turn mature mode on. What are you doing? Why Why do I see
this? What are you doing with your [__] right now?
I don't I don't know why that happened. This was in 18 plus on
kick for some reason. No good. No bueno. But thank you if you
were trying to help in some way. Maybe when slime did that. I'm
not totally sure. Yeah, that's what it was. Okay, I see. No.
No. 18 plus is not No.
Nope.
18 plus is like pretty much just for pornog like borderline content.
Okay, hold on.
I I don't even know how that got turned on. That's crazy. Oh,
give me a second. That's I I'll just send it to you, Porter Beller.
That's all I was talking about. It's all good. It's all good.
I Yeah, I don't know. You must have misclicked something. It's
all good.
Oh, whoops. Whoops. Whoops.
Okay. So, from there, we move into actual content. What are we
going to do first? Do we finish the cutie Cinderella stuff? I'm
kind of thinking about doing this Myron Sneo debate to be honest
with you. I'm not sure.
No, hold on. We'll we'll do some of the cutie stuff. Okay. We'll
do some of the cutie stuff cuz there there was just some interesting
[__] that happened. Okay.
Like uh like Valkyrie came out with a Hassanesque take. All right.
>> I I did tell >> Valkyrie reacts to Cutie Cinderella
catching heat on social media. This from 4 days ago. I was like,
"Cutie,
I do think your tone doesn't help because you inherently sound
really angry all the time.
[laughter] You sound really and she knows." I was like, "You're
very blunt."
Um, I think it's it's your tone. You're blunt and it just comes
off poorly, especially, you know, and I was like, "You're also
the whitest woman I know." And it also is just, you know, you
being so white.
Um, it just it just it doesn't help. It doesn't help. But I like
I know her. I know her heart. It's just cuz she
>> just so white. You're so white. Stop talking. You're
so white. Dude, these people are
I don't get it at all. I don't know why that's so up. I'm not
going to say it's like up white woman on white woman violence.
Yeah. The fact that Valkyrie doesn't consider herself her and
Hassan do this like shape-shifting thing where they understand
their white passing in every way. They get every privilege of
a white person and then they will feel compelled to do the you're
so white thing, right? Well, in Hassan's case, it's even worse
because Hassan never shuts up about any political opinion he
has ever because he's white passing, right? It's it's just it's
goofy. It's it's so off-putting. It's so politically nonviable.
Everybody hates it except like a tiny tiny tiny subset of people
who happen to be all of these people's viewers. I don't know
why you do it. It just seems so dumb. But
I'm sure Valkyrie caught no heat for this statement, right? I'm
sure she was fine just to being like, "You're white. You should
stop talking." >> She wants to help, but I I feel like
there's there's ways we can do it better. I I did >> like
like putting on blackface before you give your opinion. Would
that have helped?
There's ways we could do it better. Okay. Uh, yeah, here it is.
The first one. Uh, hate to hate to reference Mudahar's wife,
okay, but is she talking to Cutie or her boyfriend? I can't tell.
Yeah, precisely. Like, actually, just precisely. It's goofy that
you use this when Hassan is like extremely spiritually white.
Hassan is white in every way except ethnicity and even by ethnicity's
white passing. So, I don't I don't know. It's crazy.
All right, we're good. We're good with this. Um, I think I had
one more thing of people responding to her. And there are a whole
bunch of people who respond to Valkyrie. Okay, resist. The cutie
stuff also appear applies to Ray, by the way. Oh, hold on. >> Ray
will be at the FaZe House tomorrow, October 25th, for a girls
night at 8:00 >> I will be at Pacific >> the Faze
House for Cutie's
>> girls night
at 8:00 p.m. tomorrow or today technically.
Um, I plan to rest before I get there and do stuff. So,
I need to
>> Oh, is this is this just saying that like is this the
cutie stuff? I'm guessing this is more um cutie was catching
a lot of heat for her association with FaZe, right? Cuz the FaZe
guys, they do a lot of like homophobic jokes. They're like, "Ah,
this so gay, dude." They do a lot of homophobic jokes. And so
Cutie was getting a lot of heat for her associations with FaZe
Clan. And it's funny that this person just wants to point out
like listen Valkyrie hangs out with FaZe 2. She's doing collabs
with them too. >> Uh touch. >> Should she have to
apologize for that? >> But
we will do a long stream on Sunday. It sounds like we might do
Among Us
on Sunday and then I'll probably continue Digimon after. >> So
this another thing of like clearly Valkyrie shares Cutie's opinion
one to one, right? I'm not going to not hang out with people
cuz they're problematic in some way.
So, she shares that opinion or she's just a terrible person,
right? Like she might the only other option if she doesn't share
Cutie's opinion one to one is that she's an awful human being
who is just doing this for clout despite knowing that these people
are scum in her eyes and her audience's eyes.
At least Cutie is like, "No, I'm not scum. I like I think hanging
out with these people will make them better. I think I'll be
able to like correct them softly and we'll go in a direction
that's better for everyone. I can help them understand. If Valkyrie
doesn't believe that, then she's just like transparently being
clout driven and trying to earn money from racist people and
racist people's fans >> if we do Among Us on Sunday.
Okay. All right. Thank you guys so much. I will see you guys
on Cutie stream probably or I don't know whose stream is going
to be on, but I'll see you guys tomorrow 8:00 p.m. or today 8:00
p.m. and then Sunday long stream again. We will continue this.
Wait, Cutie is still alive.
Cutie is live.
What is she doing? Oh, she's singing. Oh my god. Yeah, let's
raid Cutie. I can't believe she >> Oh, this is this is
literally right at the time Cutie's talking about deleting the
VOD. You see the Valkyrie raid come >> That's funny. Funny
coincidence.
from here we have the cutie Cinderella response
apology
crying stream. I don't have a whole lot of reactions to this
stuff, right? I'm just going to do like the main points, but
we've got Kitty's response stream. I got to use the bathroom
real quick. I'll be right back. But I'm going to hit play and
I'll be listening. So, give me I don't know 45 to 70 seconds.
>> Hello, chat. Am I live? I cannot tell. Oh, yay. I was
like, did I break it?
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
Why is my title not updated? I hate when it does that.
Oh, well.
Hi. Hi. Hi.
It's updated. Oh,
it just didn't make it to the bot. Oh,
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello.
Hello. Hello. Hello. Hi. Hello. Oh my
This will be fun. Okay. Um,
listen. There's going to be a lot of people here. Don't tip >> I'm
back. We're ready to go. >> Watch me. I know there's a
lot of people
um for a lot of different reasons.
Um but the biggest thing I'm going to
uh to my mods
is
um
uh time people out who are just >> trying to share their
opinions. Okay. Um, and also to like chatters.
Um,
don't fight hate with hate because I've never ever ever ever
ever
wanted that. So, please, please do not do that. Um,
just, you know, let people speak their minds and that's okay.
Okay. And when in doubt, if uh you're upset with what someone
says,
let's just um
I don't want my chat to be a place for hating on other people.
Obviously, there's a lot of people that are mad at me. I totally
understand. >> I'm I should just like time this to see
how long it takes to get through this >> I get it, >> right?
It can't take that long. Can it Can it take that long? >> And
I'm not I'm not I'm for the I'm not mad at you guys for being
mad at me for the record. I I I get it. I understand.
and for the people that aren't mad at me, um, I don't think this
conversation is for you. I don't, you know, if you're not mad
at me, I don't owe you an apology. Um,
but if you are mad at me, I I do owe you an apology. If I
hurt you, I do owe people that I hurt
uh an apology. So, that's what's most important to me. Um,
so I understand
I understand um I understand that there's a lot of opinions,
but something that's important to me and has always been important
to me is um that if I if I hurt someone, I owe them an apology.
And that's not like that's >> Dude, what did you do? I'm
sorry. You could apologize, but that implies if you want to apologize,
you have to say what you did wrong, right? And it can't just
be like,
"Huh,
she's going to do the like, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry that I didn't think about a way to say that better."
And it's like, it's not the way you said it that actually upset
them. I'm sorry. It's the idea that that the people who have
opinions like your stepfather can be bartered with, can be like
bargained with, talked to, changed in any way. That is the concept.
They are angry about the concept. Okay?
They're not angry about the way you said it. There is no way
to deliver the words you mean, the concept you mean without them
being >> That's just who I am as a person. No matter who
I hurt, like that's just who I am. So, just a lot to talk about.
Turn off ads. Oh.
Uh, I didn't. [laughter]
>> Do you see what I mean? Turn off the ads. You're apologizing
to us. Turn off the ads, [__] ads were running. How
do I do that?
Um, [clears throat]
yeah, I do think the bare minimum is apologizing to people that
you hurt. I do think so. Oh, my mod is going to turn off my ads.
Okay, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Um, okay. I'm going to
wait till I get confirmation
that the ads are gone. Are they out of here? I'm going to uh
try to read chat, but I understand um
kind of a lot going on right now. Should be off. Thank you.
okay. Uh also, like I said, I I know a lot of people
um
uh I would >> I don't know how to explain this. Okay. The
music is making it depressing. That's actually my music that
I edit in unironically. I know some people might want to jump
past this. There's some sick part of me that likes watching how
they like have to they like have to psych themselves up to say
the things that they don't believe in like these situations.
Like when cutie showing up to apologize right now, you know that
when she talks to Ludwig in private, she's like, "These people
I can't stand I can't stand these people anymore. I'm about to
lose it. I'm about. And then she has to show up and she has to
like psych herself up to be like,
"Okay. Um, okay. Just just tell them that like nobody deserves
to be hurt and load up every platitude you can and uh we'll get
through this. Okay. We'll get through this, cutie. We'll get
through it." >> You put eight ads on an apology stream.
I have a bot that runs ads. Um,
and I uh forgot to turn it off, but my mod just turned it off.
So, uh,
that's just a misunderstanding. That's it's automatic. Um, there's
actually a few things that are, uh, have been out of my hands,
um, that people are mad at me for. Um, but, you know, I'll explain
that and >> I'm looking forward to explaining it. >> This
is a little >> This is literally not working. Okay, now
it's working. Kind of >> overwhelming at the moment, admittedly.
I'm trying not to get distracted. I'm not a a professional as
at this. But, uh, you're literally a professional at this. You
are. You are actually literally a professional at this. This
is your professional job.
It's It's
literally your job. I have to restart this window. It's like
crashing on me or something. It's like all laggy and crap.
>> But yeah, it is it is quite literally your job.
>> guys, I'm not I'm not a professional at this. I've only
been doing this for my entire adult life. This is the only true
career I've ever had. But I'm not a professional at this. >> Okay,
maybe
um
uh I'm just going to go ahead and close
chat. Do you want slow mode or unique mode? Um, maybe both would
be helpful. Thank you. Sorry.
I have never done something like this. Um, but uh, >> she's
never apologized for something
Um, yeah, I think she's she's almost she's got to be a millionaire
from Twitch at this point. Yes.
And yeah, she's acting like she's
I feel like she's apologized before. I feel like she said some
pretty inappropriate [__] before. She certainly on
that one girl. I remember we watched the stream of her like totally
on a girl who I think was like hanging out with Bisk
or something. I can't remember the stream now. Zezy would know
if Zezy were here. There was like a stream we watch of cutie
on this girl. I would have assumed she went back and apologized
for >> Uh ads
ads should be off and everyone should be good. And again, um
if if you don't think I there's a few people in here that are
saying I don't need to apologize. If you don't think I need to
apologize, then this apology isn't for you. So,
so you don't need it. But
regardless, if I hurt anyone, I I like to apologize to people
that I've hurt. And that's just something about me. Um, and I've
I've heard what a lot of people are saying. I've heard what [clears throat]
a lot of people are saying, and I I am
sorry for the like the hurt that I've caused
Dude, I Uhuh. She's loading it up. She's loaded up 99%. >> I'm
really sorry. Like,
uh,
again, if you if you don't want this apology, then it's not for
you. And clearly, you're not hurt, but I'm apologizing to people
that I've hurt, and that's important to me. Um, so if you are
a part of the queer community and I've hurt you, I am I am sorry.
If you are a person of color who I have hurt, I am sorry.
I am. I I really am. Um, >> in what universe did she hurt
people of color? What did she say at any point here hurt people
of color? Why is she just apologizing? Hey, uh, also, you know,
just generally, if by being white I offended black people, I
I apologize for that. Valkyrie, I'm so sorry if I offended Latino
people. Latinx, the Latinx of the world, by being white, I apologize.
I think
the way I was wording things was very like irresponsible and
wrong
and I'm sorry. Um,
okay. I will, by the way, I will let a ton of this stuff go.
all of the preloaded garbage she's doing here, I can let all
of it go so long as she maintains the principal position, right?
And just tries to word it differently. If she on the principal
or says I shouldn't ever say this,
I I'm This is crazy. All right.
I don't know which way it's going to go. We got 25 minutes left
on it. I don't know which way it's going to go. I don't know
where she actually goes with it. I'm just saying I can let even
I can let all of the theatrics go so long as she doesn't give
up the principle that she actually believes in. >> This
is not about me. I just
It's annoying that I am I'm
I'm chill. I'm fine. Um >> okay, just real quick for Exormy.
Exormy asked like what she did that got her in this trouble.
So she was on a stream with some lefty creators. One particularly
large lefty creator's got a big base on Tik Tok and she said
in in the course of a conversation she said, "Well, I don't believe
in cutting people off because they're bigoted. Like my stepdad
is bigoted. He doesn't he doesn't appreciate my stepbrother's
gender uh transition doesn't appreciate her or his sorry gender
transition." And they fight about it, but I don't cut him off
because I don't believe that's the way you change people's minds.
I believe you you could be kind to people who are bigoted in
some way and try to get them to change slowly over time. I think
I think it's important I don't cut my father off even though
my stepbrother doesn't like talking to him. My stepbrother doesn't
judge me for still talking to them. And I think that's the way
you win people's hearts and minds is you don't treat them like
monsters. You try to explain why the things they do are hurtful,
why they're harmful, and you move on from there. And then she
also said the same thing about the FaZe Clan people that sometimes
they're like homophobic, but she doesn't want to just cut them
off because she thinks she can help them be better. Now, is that
true or the fact that they all have like 15 to 20,000 concurrent
at minimum? Well, it's a little column A, little column B. Okay,
but these people were freaking out and then they try to say because
they immediately know they have no ground to stand on here. They
try to say then that it's like, oh, it's the way she said it.
Oh, it's just inappropriate to have the conversation in public.
None of those things are even true. But even if they were, that's
not what they're upset about. They're upset about the idea that
the they've cut off like everybody in their life who's ever even
remotely uttered a bigoted thing. And if you aren't willing to
take that extreme step and be in the cult with them, you
I just I I
don't I don't articulate myself well. Um which means I can't
really be upset um if what I'm trying to convey is misunderstood.
Um because like don't get me wrong, at first I was like, "How
could that be taken this way?" And then I listened and I learned
and I said, "Oh my god, cuz it wasn't my intention, but I did
articulate things very irresponsibly." And that that sucks.
Um
I I I did a really poor job at articulating myself. Even some
of the clips I've seen,
I feel so irresponsible for my own wording. I really do. Um,
and I'm sorry for that. >> Okay. What's So, so I will say
there's one clip where there's bad wording, but she fixes the
bad wording like 30 seconds later. Right. There is one clip where
you could interpret it a certain way. It's like worded badly.
If you if you take but you don't apologize for that. You say,
"I understand that this hurt your feelings. If you watch a little
deeper into the stream, you'll see that it's clipchimped. It's
not actually my full opinion. I said this. Here's like the example."
And you move >> I watched it back. I understand why it
was hurtful. I've read the comments, believe it or not. Um
I uh have gotten a lot of feedback. Um I've reached out to people
personally obviously um that may or may not have been affected
by this. I just, you know, wanted to make sure. Um,
but I watched it back and I I understand even the tone of my
voice um is very flippant and defensive and I understand that
that's a problem. >> It wasn't It literally wasn't flippant.
It's maybe the most sincere
I've ever heard Cutie Cinderella be is like she truly believed
these things. It's not flippant. It wasn't flippant. You thought
about it a lot. Clearly, this was like something you actually
cared about. The rest of the time I hear this [__]
speak, it's all meaningless platitudes. This is the one time
I've ever heard her and been like, "Oh, that's like kind of surprising.
Oh, that's really interesting, actually." Like that she would
have that opinion. I wouldn't have expected that given her like
friend group, given who she usually hangs out with. I would have
expected her to not have that opinion. Booby Booby, I just said
it 30 seconds ago. >> I've always struggled with my tone
of voice. Uh it's like a persistent problem of mine as >> she's
she's apologizing now for like resting bit face resting big voice
which is not even their criticism >> as well as articulating
my thoughts correctly. Um I didn't go live right away uh to make
sure I could gather my thoughts and and and
try to articulate them correctly.
Um, I I think
I just need to like
uh that I know that I'm privileged because I can move through
these spaces and exist safely without being threatened in a way
that queer, trans, and people of color are threatened. Um,
I have always
uh
I've always viewed my role as someone who cares about marginalized
communities and I've always viewed my role as a supporter and
an ally, but sometimes to be a good ally, you need to shut up
and listen. Um, and I know that and I'm sorry if it seemed like
I didn't know >> You this whole like this way of behaving
is just setting a precedent for like the rest of your life. If
this feels even 1% out of place for Cutie, just this totally
like totally kneeling down and and having people like be like
throw tomatoes at you. If this is what you want for your life,
then continue. But like you're setting this precedent that when
you do something that you believe in and you just or let me be
slightly big about it, which is something you say you have to
work on. You say it's like it's literally just a thing that or
Valkyrie says is a thing you always have happen. Right? If you
sit here and you out on this on a thing you truly believed in,
you go, "Oh, yeah, I know. I'm sorry, guys." For for an audience,
okay, you're not doing it for a family member. You're not doing
it to like make somebody you care about happy. You're doing it
for people who don't really give a who are only here to try to
do this to you, right?
If you do it, it's just going to continue. It's going to happen
again and again and again. At some point, you have to decide
whether or not you're going to stand tall and lose some viewers
who are probably not there for your
not there with your best interest in mind or if you're going
to have this be the pattern that happens for the rest of time.
You just have to make that decision. I just think
like
I think overall
uh I I really do
try to be a positive influence. I really do. Um, but the way
I articulate it, I ignored how privileged I am to be able to
navigate my relationships that way. Um,
I didn't make it clear that I'll I'll always fight bigotry and
I'll always try to be a good role model and a good influence.
But I want to be a good ally and I I want to be a positive influence,
not just for streamers, but for like very young and impressionable
audiences. I I know that that role can't fall on people who are
directly threatened or affected.
And I'm sorry if you know I'm sorry that I did hurt people in
this community and other communities. Um that was never my
Um I uh >> Oh, don't worry even less. Based on everything
I hear these people say, they basically go live and repeat the
same four points for like 45 minutes while collecting donations.
Although I don't know if she's collecting donations. Okay. Uh,
I have conversations with go live and they spew out the same
over and over and over and over again. >> Um, to try to
like evoke streaming in the or evoke streaming evoke uh progress
in the streaming space. Um,
and I do so with hope that uh it can be more welcoming. I I think
I have been very true to
uh building bridges. I've always said that that's my goal. Um,
and I will always that will always be my
Um, yes, like my mod just said, chat, this is not your place
to fight with other chatters. Please uh
please do not do that. Um, that is I I'm asked by mods not to
ban people, but uh if you are being uh directly hateful to somebody,
then you will be banned if you're being hateful. Um, if you're
just sharing your opinion, I understand. And I I'm, you know,
hoping to see some of them and listen. Um, but if you're just
being hateful to somebody else in chat, not towards me, you can
be hateful towards me. I already told my >> my mods not
to ban that. If you
>> If people want to get mad at me, let them say whatever
they want about me, guys. Okay? Let them They can go as hard
as Dude, she just wants to be Maybe she's just a total masochist.
Maybe she just hates herself and she wants to get like absolutely
abused by everybody around her. Maybe that's like her whole existence
online cuz nothing else makes
>> you know?
Um but if you're being hateful to someone else in chat or another
streamer, that's not what I'm about. I've never been about that.
So,
uh yeah, I think um I don't know. I think I just I I hope I can
um I hope I can prove my purpose in this space um through listening
to lived experiences of people that are affected. And it's feels
awful that it seemed to some people that I'm just comfortable
with bigotry. Um I'm not a bigoted person. I'm not. Uh that's
just not who I am.
>> Uh and I'll continue to show that. Um, but I understand
if you don't accept my
and I understand
um
if if you're still mad at me, but I I'm still very sorry. I understand
if you don't feel safe watching me. >> Oh, this is a funny
opinion. Plant dad mixed man here. It's incredibly insulting
that she's so subservient to minorities. She's not treating us
like equals, treating them as equals.
Um,
yeah, but I don't even know. Is that like I don't know how to
I don't know how to even like explain this. It's just it's so
offputting to me that somebody would come out and do this that
this is like this is the exact thing I don't like. Um yeah, just
people like apologizing for the race when they're like race for
no reason. Like you shouldn't feel bad about your race. You don't
have to take pride in your race. That's a fairly stupid thing.
But you don't have to feel bad about it. And like all these people
come out and do the race thing and then also just saying things
she didn't do like I'm sorry. I'm sorry if I offended you as
a person of color. How could you have done that? Why are you
apologizing for things that didn't happen? I There's another
way to look at that, by the way, plant dad. Not that she's being
incredibly subservient. She's treating people like the She's
treating people like they don't understand what's actually happening.
Like that there's no way. She almost certainly understands that
there's no way she could have offended somebody who's like a
person of color with what she said.
She has to know that, right? But she's still going to say sorry
for it because somebody accused her of it. She's just going to
apologize for everything she's been accused of, no matter what.
No matter if it applies, no matter if she thinks she did it,
>> or if you don't feel safe watching my collaborations,
I understand that.
Um,
>> I hope to prove to you that my community is a safe space.
My community even isn't isn't even who's watching right now.
Um, it's very >> Do you think this is like a symptom of
racism kind of being solved on a macro level? Like it's not like
there are still many many versions of racism that exist. I'm
not going to really deny that. I don't I don't care to deny that.
But on a macro level like fundamentally like large scale racism
has been kind of defeated in the US. Okay. Do you think this
is like a symptom where it's these people wanted to be on the
side of black people? They wanted to uplift minorities and and
you know you know any minority identity group, right? They wanted
to uplift. But now it's like they've been uplifted and it's like
what do you do after that? Well, you have to start like apologizing
for the past. You have to start apologizing for things that didn't
happen in order to get that same feeling.
Like these are people who are like trying to relive something
that they missed or I I don't know like some sort of social justice
movement that did happen that there was like a resistance against
some majority group who was oppressing people and they've kind
of won everything now and it's like okay well now I just have
to make things up. I have to tell I have to let these people
tell me that I've offended them so that I can then try to make
them feel better. It's like it's like synthetically creating
oppression.
She's she's absolutely producing synthetic oppression with her
audience so that she can now apologize for said synthetic >> I
just hope to prove that to you is all. Um but
um again, and then obviously like
I'm sorry I keep looking at chat. I'm not trying to look at chat,
but it's just hard when I know a lot of you have a lot of things
you want to say. Um,
a as for being upset that I dragged Katie and Vanilla into the
conversation, that's fair and valid. Um,
it's that's so fair and valid, and I was so wrong for that. I
shouldn't have brought it up. Um,
Vanilla and I have had multiple conversations in the last few
weeks about the internet being difficult to navigate and exist
in lately. And >> it's not. It's really not. You create
the environment. You're the streamer. You create the environment
you exist in. It's super not hard. I guarantee you I deal with
uh I don't I don't even really like care to talk about it, but
like you just you decide what affects you. You decide what you
want to acknowledge,
right? The internet doesn't have to be a hard place to navigate.
You gave an opinion that if you gave that opinion on Asen Gold
stream, nobody even gets mad at you at all. Actually, hold on.
If you gave that opinion on 99.9%
of streams on Twitch, nobody gets mad at you. You've created
the area where people can get mad at you and you accept it and
you validate and you say that's okay. You get to decide whether
you want that or not. So, stop sitting here and pretending that,
oh, the internet's so hard to deal with. It's really not.
You're the person making it difficult for yourself. >> I
started ranting inappropriately. I I won't pretend like that
was the space for that. It wasn't. Um,
you know, I I'm an for bringing it up. It's it just there's a
time and a place and uh >> you're not an for bringing it
up >> and I'm really sorry. Uh if >> you're literally
a streamer, the people are there to hear your thoughts unless
you set up something else, right? The people are there to hear
your thoughts. Anybody who ever questions, this is the the easy
thing for a streamer. You never ever ever
get mad at somebody for disagreeing with you. But if anybody
ever goes to your stream and tells you in your chat, "Hey, you
shouldn't say what you want to say right now." Ban them immediately.
Just ban them, right? They can disagree. Don't ban them for disagreeing.
But if they're just going to go, "Hey, uh, you shouldn't say
that."
Get them get them out. Nope. You can actually make a criticism.
You can actually say something substantial or you can [__]
because as soon as you start validating that, like them actually
just controlling the things you say and do, right? that that's
like a paradigm you want to set. You you get trapped in this.
You you become a slave. Okay? A slave on a plantation of your
own design, of your own making, the plantation of your mind.
All right? Don't do that. That's crazy. All right? Anybody tells
you, "Oh, you should never talk about this. This is the wrong
place time to talk about this." No, it's not the wrong time to
talk about it. It's something you care about. It's your stream.
I get that it's a collaboration, but it's with a bunch of people
who care about these issues. It's actually with people who disagree
with you. That's maybe the healthiest time to express that. Hey,
I have a feeling that this is an opinion you disagree with. I
respect you. I want to have this conversation.
Why not? Why is that something? Why have you all created environments
where that is a harmful thing to do? I have no idea. It's It's
baffling to me. >> If you felt uncomfortable during that,
um I know I I have a problem reading the
it's like
actually pretty embarrassing. I think she might that might actually
be true that she has a problem reading the room. I don't think
that's what happened here, which is pretty up because now you're
like making her think it's her fault or or she did something
wrong that's leading to her like misreading the situation or
or leading her to think she misread the situation, but she didn't.
She's probably acting like just a normal person here. She's literally
just facing the other direction. Almost certainly when she turns
back, she's going to be balling her eyes out. Right. This is
This is She's looking away because she started crying and she
doesn't want to look back at the camera while she's crying, right?
>> Um but regardless, I uh
I I lack I lack social cues. I lack social awareness. Um this
is something I've dealt with my whole life.
>> But um that's that's my fault. I I really struggled
to read social situations. I've talked about it for for many
many uh years that I struggle with social situations and so I
feel like an idiot whenever
that does happen. Um
and I feel stupid. I feel really really dumb and I feel embarrassed
and I feel like an [__] and I've and I've apologized
to Katie and and Vanilla individually. Um again, there's a time
and a place and I did not. [laughter] >> Baffling absolutely
baffling.
I did not I I
am sorry for that. Um
I'm sorry to the communities that watched it that were uncomfortable.
I know you guys didn't sign up for that. We were supposed to
be playing video games.
So I am I'm sorry to you guys. Um I I I
hate that I made you uncomfortable.
>> I I >> Well, why would you say this? This is a
wild opinion. you know, I will not
um be asking them to collab anytime soon. Uh
I I
would that's not
that's not their fault. Um and I hate to see that they've been
dragged into any of this. I don't think that's fair at all. Um
I it makes me really really sad that because I can't read a social
situation that they've been dragged.
That's really not It's not fair to them. It It's not fair to
them. And I don't
um
And I don't like that people are dragging them because of things
I said. So, if anything, uh please just,
you know, leave them out of it. Um
would this be Kino? I don't think this makes any sense. That's
like a downgrade in terms of everything except maybe raw dollars,
but Lwig has like so much money it's just at diminishing returns
anyway. So, I just that doesn't make any sense. That would be
the weirdest thing to have >> Um,
this is my fault. I shouldn't have brought it up. I should have
read the >> If I could go back in time, it'd be so different.
But I'm I'm just sorry. I'm
a few other things. I've seen I've seen you guys
talk about it. Um, there's been a lot of confusion about the
VOD being
>> Asia, I just I honestly, you should like find a different
community. Honestly, the way you suck off Asminold is just so
disgusting. Like that you can think that Hassan is a worse person
than Asminold when Asmin Gold's a Trump supporter. He is doing
the most apologia for Trump on the planet. You should just right
off. Honestly, leave. Don't come back. come back if you fix your
brain ever. All >> vanilla clarified. >> It's just
I and honestly, I could sit here and like not pay any attention
to it because you've been here for a long time, but the fact
that you like you do this and you're like going in and you're
like pricing as gold in my chat, like I actually just I'm going
to fly into a rage at some point. So
I And again, I have no issues with like Asmold on a personal
level, how he deals with people interpersonally, but I just know
for a fact that you get super as mad about any pro- Hassan take
at all. and love Asthma Gold, right? And to me, I'm like, oh,
like one of them does Apologia for a fascist takeover of your
country and the other one is like a totally narcissistic
brat boy that at best at at worst runs Apologia for like an ideology
that has no political background or sorry, no political backing
and no political capital in your country.
It's just like it's not even it's not even a little bit close
>> on her stream. So like these are her words. They are
not mine. Um, well, I guess they're mine because they're coming
out of my mouth. So, sorry about that. That was stupid. Um,
that it was her idea
um to delete the VODs. She wanted to edit out where we talked.
Um,
I I don't know how to do that. I have uh one of my mods uh does
that for me whenever we do edited segments. And >> oh,
I will also say I totally agree with Asmin Gold on this Kitty
Cinderella thing. Like I think I agree nearly one to one with
his opinion. So it's like not even that I don't think he has
the right take on this. I just uh I just I see you talking and
I know like how you feel about the Hassan coverage and you're
here to suck off as weird to me. >> So I said I'll just
delete mine. Um
uh but you did push it hard cuz she was uncomfortable and so
once she stated that she was >> uh Yes.
Yes. Like unironically. Yes. Yep. Yeah. I I understand you can't
un you can't unravel their belief systems and like understand
what points they're making, but I can and that's what makes it
>> It was uncomfortable. That's when I'm able to read the
room. Um
so once I'm told that someone like once I'm able to understand
that she was uncomfortable, I'm obviously
um I'm obviously
going to oblige with her request. I
um I wasn't forcing >> I mean yeah you don't literally
have to leave. It is true to have it's true it's good to have
a dissenting voice. You don't actually have to leave but uh I
just had to get that comment out. Okay. So stay if you want >> anyone
to delete the VODs. I didn't even realize
uh at the time
how poor my tone was, how poor my articulation was. I didn't
I didn't know that. Um
I Vanilla said she was uncomfortable and she thought people were
going to take clips out of context. She was correct. Um, and
she was correct in being uncomfortable and I'm happy that she
said something and I'm happy that she uh was >> she literally
said she agreed with you. She literally was like, "Oh, yeah.
No, no, you should be saying this. No, say what you want." She
literally in the moment was like nodding. She was like, "No,
no, no. You should feel comfortable. We love you, cutie." >> Comfortable
enough to ask for the VODs deleted. And I'm happy that we
>> um because that's what she wanted. Um,
and then there's been a big a really big
misconception about DMCA strikes. Um, since the VOD was deleted,
I since the VOD was deleted, I did a singing stream after. I've
been wanting to do a singing
I you can if you watch me, you know that. And whenever I do singing
streams, I delete the VOD because I'm embarrassed of my singing.
And I started the singing stream. Um,
and I did I I played some of or I sang some of my unreleased
music. Um, I sang three of my my unreleased songs and then people
were threatening to upload that and so yes, admittedly I was
on edge and I was being a [__] uh about that. Um,
>> so this I've heard different takes on this. I've heard
totally divergent takes on this that she really was singing.
She really didn't want her music uploaded at all. And then I've
heard that yeah, she's totally faking it. Right. Let's watch
a singing stream. We could watch her singing at the end of that
stream if we wanted to. I don't particularly want to, right?
But I I also don't know. Like I've seen some evidence that she
could be talking mostly about her singing.
It's it's difficult unless you want to go and sit through because
she tends to do this thing. Okay,
she's very queen and coded in some cases. All right, she tends
to do this thing where when she's like reading chat or when she's
annoyed, she just sits there silently for 15 seconds at a time.
Says three words and then sits there for another 15 seconds.
Says three words 15 3 15 just over and over again, right? Just
taking these same breaks over and over again.
And I I recognize that even saying this now that that might happen.
Um that people might upload my unreleased songs. Um but I just
I wanted I wanted to clear the record and I was only thinking
of my music being released. Um but I understand how that's being
perceived now as Cutie is,
you know, copy striking anyone that posted the combo. I I'm not
I I've not sent out one coffee strike. If uh even if you talked
about doing it, I uh the threat is like enough for a lot of people.
The threat shouldn't be made. >> Uploaded my music. I
I don't know if I'd do anything. So that's
um it sucks that that's where it went. I have, you know, my I
even went into my mod Discord the second it happened and I said,
"If you see anyone upload my music, let me know." That's what
it was about. It was about my music that I've worked. Anyway,
>> she's close to crying. Guys, if you're on the Twitch
stream, you want to see her cry, head over to kick.com/jlk,
I'm ending the Twitch stream. All right, we're going to end the
Twitch stream right now.
We'll see you guys in just a little bit. Also, I need to show
real quick. We're just about at two hours left on the stream,
guys. If you like the content, I want you to follow on every
platform on X and Twitch. It's JSLK_.
Everywhere else, it's JSOK. All right. Follow on Patreon. Join
the Discord.
Go follow and everything. All right.
And if you really like the content, go ahead, throw a couple
bucks my way. Add some more time to the stream. You could sub
on kick. You could gift Twitch Primes. You could gift on Twitch
kick. You could do whatever you want for for subbing. All right.
You could buy TTS message. Exclamation point. Donate in the chat.
We'll give you those links. All right.
Exclamation point donate. And last but not least, there's always
the Patreon as well. patreon.com/jstk.
There's multiple tiers that you could sign up at. Uh, for some
reason it no longer shows the tiers when I go to my actual Patreon.
Kind of odd to be honest with you,
but it's fine. Wait, if I go like this, is it going to change
and show the tiers? Oh, it does. Okay. Well, you see how many
people are at each tier as well? Damn. Okay.
Anyway,
All right. Go sign up. Multiple different tiers.
It's a great time. Okay, guys. All right. Thank you for listening
to the shill. Let's continue on with the kickstream. >> And
then as for the blocking on Twitter,
uh
if you again, a lot of this is coming from a lot of people
um a lot of people that don't follow me and don't >> Oh,
hold on. What is this? Is a short
>> worth a play.
>> What is this? Oh, cutie Cinderella's
I would have never [singing] let you go.
It's been years now.
>> this is so cool.
>> I'm like I like don't watch music videos. I just get
the sense that this is like a
I I get the sense that this isn't like modern music videos. She
like watched music videos in the 2000s and she like she's basically
on her Tim Pool arc. That's how I see it. She's doing the music
she listened to. She's doing like the the the period piece of
music video and it's just like she's she's 100% Timing it.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Everybody Everybody else Yeah, I know she's
a Swifty, but I didn't get the vibe of like any Taylor Swift
video I'd seen. So maybe it's like older Taylor Swift. I get
the Tim Pool vibe. I'm going to recreate Tim Pool is like I'm
gonna remake Nickelback right
>> Anyway, I Yeah, not cool. Not great. Not the best. know
me. Um, but if if you if you do follow me, uh, you know that
I literally like I don't have I don't have Twitter on my phone.
I don't have access to it. Twitter is bad for my mental health.
If you've followed me for a long
you know that I have multiple mods that I pay to block people
on Twitter.
>> Oh, that's why I'm blocked. That'sed up. I I think this
is fine. You should never apologize for blocking somebody on
Twitter. You could you could ask if you want to apologize, what
you should do is say, "Here's how you apply for an unblock. Just
tell me what happened." Right? If you want to apologize, but
don't apologize for actually blocking people.
That's your prerogative. >> This is I've done this for
years. Um
my team
uh does not differentiate hate online. Um I do I do get a lot
of hate. Um, I don't I don't look at it for my own mental health,
but I have a whole team that blocks people. Um, I assure you
it wasn't my intention to silence voices. Uh,
I have I've heard the upset. I
I've told them to stop blocking people. So, you should not get
blocked now. Um,
I I do want to listen to your lived >> Silencing voices
telling me to myself. That's uh that's horrible for you, cutie.
You're silencing voices of people telling you that you should
die. Oh, I never Hold on. I hadn't ended the Twitch stream. Whoops.
I just realized. But it's ended now. So, luckily. Okay. Whoops.
I like I said that and then I somebody sent a message on Twitch
and I'm like, what the All right, we're we're on kick only now.
Get rid of that VOD, too, real quick.
>> I'm sorry
that those voices were silenced. Um, I understand why people
are really hungry to have this conversation. Um, and and you
deserve an outlet and I'm sorry it was put on deaf ears. I'm
sorry that the
balance between criticism and actual uh like feedback
was thin and
um
and yeah, my my team banned you. I'm not I I'm not I'm not going
to blame
uh like my I'm not mad at my team for that. They were just doing
their jobs. Um I
have told them to stop. You can share.
you know I
I promise to continue to educate myself. I'm not I will never
stop educating myself.
>> She's like now just spinning the wheel to different
catchphrases of lefties. All right. I'll never stop educating
myself. I know. I'll never stop doing I'll never stop doing it.
I'll never stop doing it. Right. [laughter] Please stop. Somebody
tell me it's okay. Somebody tell me that you've forgiven me.
Please. Please.
Uh, Marmadoo with the 500 kicks says, "Guys, I hope we learned
a valuable lesson from this apology stream. If you're white,
you ain't right. Time to sit your white ass down and listen."
Thank you very much for the five, Marma, dude. Appreciate it.
>> Ever. Like, that's not
that I do. Um,
I know a lot of people
going to be mad and stay >> Yeah, we've said that. I know
a lot of you, you shouldn't feel bad about their about being
upset with me. You shouldn't feel bad about that, guys. >> mad.
And >> I should have like run this transcript through something,
gotten like the top five phrases and just put them in buckets
and let them add up as it goes, right? Cuz I swear to God, we've
heard the same like four or five phrases over and over and over
again. I don't want to tell you not to be upset. I don't want
to silence any voices. I am constantly educating myself, okay?
I know that what I said was taken out of context or sorry that
I know that I can say things the wrong way. I can't I can't observe
social cues. >> That's okay. >> Wow. I understand.
>> Are we apologizing for bad behavior or for other people
being mad? Both.
Well, hold on. The bad behavior is like her unintentionally making
people upset. >> But I I do believe this got to corners
of the internet that I have never been a part of. Um I could
never expect
strangers to know my intention. Um but I'll always stand for
building bridges. I will always stand for that.
Do you think like uh do you think people like Asmin Gold take
her side just knowing that that's going to her with that group
of people too? Like you know when she when she got the O notification
of like Asmin Gold defends Cutie Cinderella, you know, she just
like chucked her phone at the [__] wall, right? [__]
Asmin Gold, right? Like the second she saw that she was like
she knew she was done. She has to go apologize now. Asmin Gold
supported me. It's over. It's over. I I'm I'm locked in. I have
to apologize. She doesn't have Twitter. She does have Twitter,
but I'm just telling you, she just she like lost it when she
saw that Asmin Gold was defending her. It was over. Okay, you
can keep saying she doesn't have Twitter, but she refers to a
lot. She sure knew a lot about Shot Color Gate without having
looked at anything,
That doesn't mean people need to use them, but I hope to I hope
to be a good role model. It's all I've ever worked on. So, I
hope to continue
doing that and continue being a positive influence. um is all
but I am trying to read chat but I don't know if it's entirely
um at the moment. >> Wait, what is it saying?
We love you. Twitch lately has been pretty hard to watch. Honestly,
everything feels so polarized now. Even streamers I felt safe
watching are getting into those issues. Hope you're taking care
of yourself. Everyone deserves the chance to grow. Are you still
going to hang out with the boys aka FaZe Clan?
Uh let's see here. This is not scrolling down yet. Do not read
chat. I love seeing you bake. You're all right. People don't
talk enough about how hard it is to just consistently form coherent
sentences when you have anxiety, too. FaZe Vanilla tried her
best to fix what has happened, and these Faze kids are trying
to blame her for it. Oh. Oh, there's like a war happening. Okay.
Yeah, Cutie Cutie's kind of [__] here. Cutie doesn't
want to offend anybody, right? But there are people like Asmin
Golden and the FaZe Clan guys who are going to take her side
and say this this vanilla mace person is dog, right? And then
the vanilla mace person is going to get harassment. And then
the vanilla mace community and then probably adjacent Tik Tok
communities will go as Golden and Faze are defending cutie
cutie those guys right and she's just going to be torn us under
because she won't stand on business in either
>> because um
>> chat's not chat is not productive right >> Going
a little fast.
Um, again, there's more people mad about the blocking and the
cease and desist and the deleted VODs. I covered that. Uh, feel
free to watch it back. Um,
no one will be blocked on Twitter anymore. So, feel free to post
whatever. Again, I I literally
I I'm showing you I don't have the app. I go to it on my phone.
It's restricted. I don't I didn't like
I we do block and have always blocked people that were hateful.
Um,
and I'm really I'm really sorry. I'm really sorry that you felt
like not you felt that's not fair. I'm really sorry that by blocking
criticism I was silencing voices and stories. Um, that wasn't
my intention. Okay. I don't know
um if there's
any more of a like productive conversation I can have right now.
Um
because again a lot of these people
uh a lot of people in chat right now aren't uh necessarily a
part of my community.
>> hold on, hold on. This guy's name just keeps popping
up in places. We might cover some This isn't This isn't the Tony,
right? Teeny Tony,
Teeny Tony.
We got Teeny Tony and Teeny Tiny Tony now. Teeny Tony, longtime
cutie Cinderella
community member maybe. and
>> but just
know that I hope
>> weird stuff.
>> You come back and visit and see that my community is
a safe space uh for everybody. Um but if you don't feel that
way, I totally respect it. I I totally totally respect it. So,
um I also
know that there's been, you know,
uh Tik Tok posts and stuff like that on my Tik Tok. Again, I
don't run my Tik Tok. I don't have it on my phone, but I've also
asked my social media manager to stop posting Tik Toks for a
while. And also like
uh I >> Bro, it's like actually I don't know.
Uh, I just feel like
did why did she pick the worst job for her,
right?
Like she she literally picked the worst job possible for her.
>> Just like social media is
very bad for me. I stay off of it. Um,
>> I have a lot of pieces in place of other people that
manage those things. And I'll say it again. There's not one person
that has been sent a cease and desist from me because I was talking
about my music. I was talking about my unreleased music that
a lot of people have worked on and I was trying to protect that.
You leaked it though. Yes. To 2,000 people watching live, which
is something I've done many times. I didn't leak it. I didn't
I
also just to be clear
I get I guarantee you she's given like a bunch of super hateful
alogs
a total license to publish all this [__] like all
over the place, right? She has to understand that she's just
like said the thing that upsets her is the music. If that actually
does upset you, you're not joking. You've just given people like
a thing they're absolutely going to press on, which is >> Link
my music to choice. upload it onto YouTube or for other people
to make money off of it. Um, that's not what I was that's not
what I was doing. I
sang it to my audience
that I had. I I would hope that no one would
go against what I'm sharing. >> What an incredibly I honestly
thought this was going to be something. I thought this whole
thing was going to be a thing and it's just not a thing at all.
It's like so boring.
But yeah, >> like I thought she was going to cry and she
teared up a little bit. But honestly, it's just a whole lot of
out to the worst kinds of people.
sucks. Even people right now saying I'm focusing or I'm faking
my voice sucks. But
this is all I can do. So,
um, all right. Well, I appreciate you guys. Um,
for those of you that
uh, all right, it's time to go, I think. But regardless, I am
happy to have apologized to those who deserve an apology. Um,
you can take it. You don't have to take it. I understand. I legitimately
think that she knew she only had like 5 minutes of material to
go on and that she stayed here for 30 minutes so people could
yell at her because she feels like that is like a sign of something
that she let chatters call her a piece of for like 30 minutes.
>> yeah, I know this is true only it's by and large like
massively over overwhelmingly positive comments towards her.
Yep.
Um, I will see you guys
another time.
I don't know when, but I'll see you guys another time. But, uh,
okay. Bye. Yeah, that was a that I figured that statement might
go in a direction. It just kind of stagnated immediately. Like,
I thought there was going to be a reason to watch it past 5 minutes
and she just never gave one. There just was nothing extra. She
was just It was just a struggle session, right? That's all it
was. She's just there to show up so people can throw tomatoes
at her, like call her a piece of [__]
That didn't even happen. Most of the people in the struggle session
were like, "You're so nice." But the four people out of a thousand
that were mean really hit home, I guess. I don't even Okay. All
right. Well, oh, guys. Uh, yeah, there's a blastoff tweet. Look,
it's Darius.
I'm kind of just We'll see what we're doing here, I think. Um,
yeah, I'm not totally sure.
What do I have next? I kind of I'm just going through backlog
right now as well. Not backlog like >> as a guest, right?
Because >> I'm like actually excited. I think I think Sneo
like actually bodies Myin in this debate, but I think as this
stuff gets older, this is already two weeks old. I kind of want
to get through some of this stuff right now.
Pific felon Darius IRL. What's he up to? Happy Halloween. I think
I saw this.
Yeah, honestly, I saw this, but it's from like a provocator who's
only looking for attention, so I I'm probably not even going
to bring it up on stream.
All right, how do we do this? If I do this, are we going to have
time left
Yeah, we'll have time left over to do the Darius stuff.
We'll hit up the Darius stuff in a little bit, guys. We're still
fairly early in the stream, so
let's uh let's check this out.
Myron's heated debate with Sneo on Islam in America. >> We
are guests here. I think >> what what does that mean? Guess
>> we're guess this is not a Muslim >> Darius should
be the prime content. Darius is the prime content. I'm just going
to leave it until after this. Uh I I think there's more stuff
being added as well. That's the other thing is like I know there's
more Darius content that I'm waiting for context on. >> So
I'm kind of chilling a little bit. >> It's not a Muslim
country. >> It's a freedom of religion country. It's a
secular country. Okay. What do you mean we're guessing? I'm a
citizen here. I'm not a guest. I No, no, no. Hold on. I'm not
a guest. I was I have a passport. I was born here. Of course.
What I'm saying is, but I'm saying the Islamic faith, the Islam
is, of course, it's your country, but what I'm saying is that
the Islamic faith is not a part of the American infrastructure.
>> Neither is Christianity. >> It's not Well, you
want to give your position there? >> Oh, [__]
>> About the Adon playing? >> Yeah. I mean, if if
you hear church
>> I This is a total flip for Sneo, isn't it? I thought
Sinko used to because he was friends because he was friends with
Nick. I thought Sneo used to take like that side of like, oh,
it's a Christian country. Of course, all the people who made
it were Christian. I thought he used to do that. This I This
feels like a total flip >> play. I mean, look, Dearborn
is is majority Muslim, right? It's a It's a small town. >> It's
about Yeah, it's like it's like 50 56 50 60 somewhere around
there. >> Points of contention. There's Dearborn and there's
also Time >> Square. I will say it's like 50 60% Muslim,
but sorry, 50 60% like Middle Eastern, but we don't know if they're
>> So, like they're from the Middle East and North Africa.
So, you can assume a majority of them probably are Muslim, but
we don't know if all of them. >> Yeah. Probably 60 70%.
But there's no like we could say 90% of >> But even in
Morocco or Saudi Arabia, there's still, you know, you hear the
adan and there's still many Christians that live there and many
>> Yeah. But like they're they're not actively asserting
their religion um publicly in these Muslim countries. >> What
do you mean? >> So, okay, my thing is this. The United
States is a Christian country. It it was founded by Protestant
Christians. >> No, it's a secular country. >> Well,
here's the thing. So, >> it's We have freedom of religion.
It's always We do. But >> by convention, it's a secular
country.
by by like the founding stock you could say they mostly had Christian
beliefs but in very intentionally they tried to make it a secular
sec secular country >> when they had the freedom of religion
and the separation of church and state that was instituted not
just for freedom of religion purposes but also because there
are fight the fights between Catholics, Baptists, Protestants
etc. So what they wanted was they wanted to separate the church
from the state so that neither can corrupt the other. Does that
make sense? So like the separation of church and state was actually
instituted to protect both institutions from corrupting each
other. The founding fathers had an opportunity to use the Bible
in the constitution and they decided not to because it's a secular
country cuz they do reference God. They do reference God. >> They
refence but they say God they don't say Jesus which is which
is more universal and they were very specific about that. Thomas
Jefferson himself he also said that he wants America. >> Yeah.
I would just imagine this is all over the federalist papers that
like it's a it's Yes. Yes. Exactly. It's it's based on the enlightenment.
Obviously, it is meant to be a secular country like a it's not
even like a secular country that could be without religion. It's
it's meant to be a country where the religions aren't the major
dividing
>> could be for the for the Muhammad. This is a quote the
Muhammadans and for the you call the Muhammed. >> That's
what he said. The Muhammadans I think it was a it was common
back then. So he specifically referenced that also in [clears throat]
the in DC there's there's a mural.
>> Sneo got his stretch out in Mecca. Sneaker got his ass
stretched out in Mecca [laughter] >> on the top on the
on the ceiling with the pieces
of different gods from all religions. >> Are you sure?
Cuz in Islam they're not supposed to depict. >> Yeah, they're
not supposed to depict but it's not you know they weren't Muslim
but yeah there is a depiction. >> Are you sure that that's
references like Islamic pro? Like cuz remember we share the same
prophets as them. So like we they they could like they they we
observe Moses, Jesus, Abra like we observe all of them as prophets.
So, >> Look, my thing is like, and even with the church
bells, like let's let's assume they've played cuz church bells
are banned in a lot of places, but let's >> I hear my >> uh
I hear this argument a little bit too as well. Uh let's see here.
Was it
was the um uh uh uh uh where am I looking for? Uh it was created
with the freedom of religion for the freedom to choose which
type of Christianity you wanted to worship. Um
I don't think that was universal. apartment in New York. >> That's
that's that's New York is I don't know what the rules are in
New York. >> Is that Sneo just said that there were other
religions referenced, >> but um but the thing is let's
assume that church bells are legal everywhere. Let's just let's
assume they're they're legal everywhere and they play them loud
and everything. This is still a Christian country. I think they
can do that. Like >> what is what does that mean? It's
a Christian country. >> This was founded by Christians.
This is a Christian nation. >> But it's we have freedom
of religion, but it's not in the the Bible's not referenced.
Jesus reference. >> We have freedom of religion, but at
the end of the day, we did not Muslims didn't. We are guests
here. We're not we're not the we are not the this is not a Muslim
nation. This was not founded by Muslims. Like at the end of the
day, the host religion gets to assert a level of um dominance.
Unfortunately, because they are the majority and they're the
ones that >> But the founding fathers didn't intend for
that. They didn't even say that. They didn't say they want Christian
dominance. If they wanted Christian dominance, if they wanted,
they would have included the Bible in the Constitution. They
would have said Jesus. Well, they they did that, like I said
before, to avoid, you know, issues between Baptists and Protestants
and Catholics because there this was an issue back in Europe
with the church and the state being involved and intertwined.
But when they forged it, they didn't expect, oh yeah, we're going
to have freedom of religion, but another
um I mean, you would think I don't even know if I agree with
that, Cherry, but I do think that they would have made reference
to something to explicitly say it meant Christianom. Like, they
could have done that, but I think there would be other ways of
doing it. And the fact that they didn't do it anyway at all
obviously means like I understand Jesus is the most defining
factor but it could have even been like they could have kept
it to like Abrahamic fa uh Abrahamic faiths or something right
but they didn't religion come in and and dominate like let me
explain so like if you go to any of these Muslim countries right
you can practice in peace right you could practice Christianity
or your religions of peace except for I don't think paganism
is allowed in any of the Muslim countries that's a problem but
if you're a Jew or if you're a Christian or whatever you can
practice but like you can't like assert that religion openly
>> do we have to pretend out of fear for our lives or fear
of ktos that Islam is a net benefit for the United States or
western civilization as a whole not truly practice like true
Islam from the TRA I think if you have Islam as a faith that
is a little bit watered down and not fundamentalist I think Islam's
like something I wouldn't rule out of any country but unfortunately
there's more extreme like there's Wahhabism jihadism those those
kinds of things like those are obviously awful, but there are
like more there would be in the same way that there could be
like extremely fundamentalist Christians and you get like less
you go towards like progressive Christians. I'm sure the same
thing exists in Islam and I don't see a reason to outlaw the
entire faith,
I just don't see it. But >> like praying on the streets
or doing anything like that in Musls in a Muslim >> in
group in huge groups? >> Yeah, why not? >> Nah, bro.
No, >> there's there's no there's no example of that happening
of Christians not praying on the streets. But but why do they
not do it? >> Cuz Christians don't pray on the street.
>> No, but but if they did, why why don't they do it? >> Why
don't they record themselves doing it openly? >> Did I
say Torah? My bad. Uh Quran. I don't know why I said Torah. I
might be kind of in these Sharia law countries. >> That's
not Christian practice. >> I know that they respect the
host nation. I'm saying that as Muslims, we should do the same.
Like we are this is not our country. This is we did not found
this country. >> All different religions that people pray.
We could pray at home. Like my issue isn't with praying. My issue
with is with openly openly praying and disrupting others. If
you're openly praying and you're not >> So was this about
did they in Dearborn or something try to do the thing where they
play the prayers like the the Muslim prayers and they were trying
to do like the out outside praying around something and people
are saying that's a public disruption
that maybe that would make sense to me if that's like how this
all started. >> Not disrupting anybody. I don't care. Like
some dude we were I was in time school. We weren't disrupting
anybody. I was there on the front line. I made a whole vlog.
We could watch it. Yeah, >> There was no disrupt. There
was nobody was disrupted. >> It's Here's the thing. >> Not
one person there complaining. >> I guarantee you that of
course they're not going to complain cuz they don't want to be
labeled bigots. But in New York City where they're the reality
is [clears throat] people probably want to probably wanted to
go there. I guarantee you there are hundreds if not thousands
people that went there and were like, "Yo, I want to take pictures
of Time Square." And they're like, "Oh, these guys are pranking.
I can't go in now." >> It was the section right in front
of the stairs. It wasn't blocking the sidewalk. There's an open
walking area and it was that section. It was really cold that
day course and we said that and the people were still like Time
Square wasn't shut down. It wasn't a legal like it wasn't like
we had the cops or anything. We just all gathered there and >> Here's
the thing, man. Like praying in a symbolic western location that's
a tourist destiny. >> What about like Chinese
apparently this might be what they're talking about, right? This
in Sorry, not Asan. This is Sneo in Time Square with this guy
Farage Hassan. I I read I I read Hassan at the end here. Okay.
Faraj
So they're singing out here. They're doing their thing. All right.
>> These festivals that's a public display of their culture.
>> Yeah. Well, I hear the What about I I'm not a fan. Dude,
honestly, I don't think we should have any of these parades.
>> You shouldn't have parades. >> I don't I don't
think we should have cultural parades. >> There was just
a Yam Kapur celebration in New York. They >> out of here.
I I >> It's not going to happen, bro. New York is a very
diverse place. >> Here's the thing. I don't think we should
be a flag running any other flags. I don't think we should be
doing any of these parades of where these n come from. I don't
think we should be doing any of that. Personally, I think it
should be straight American
>> I don't know that uh God was only introduced into the
pledge of allegiance later on. That's very interesting. >> American
flags only. No, no other flags. I don't think people should be
openly practicing their religion and I reserve Christians to
be able to practice >> Why not the same? Like there was
the Dominican Day parade was last month. I went there did a stream.
>> Yeah. them to get out of here >> and people waving
the, you know, it's like a a big festival. It's like it's a big
celebration in New York. >> No, I don't I don't I don't
I'm not >> big about that. >> I feel like in the
major cities in the major cities where they are actually multicultural
and you do get the best of the best from around the world or
people who like actually want to be in America. I think it's
okay to do it in the major cities. I I don't love like a ton
of like enclave type celebrations in other places. I don't think
there's any way to prohibit it via the US Constitution, though.
Like, like I think it's all protected speech. So, I don't know
how you ever prevent any of this [__] right?
Yeah. My is generally the fun police. That is who he is. JB.
So, like I I like I'm like, okay, I would be annoyed in these
smaller places, right? Your voice is like 200% compared to the
vid. Uh, okay. Oh, the vids turned down a little bit. Maybe they
were loud. All right.
Yeah. So I
like me personally I understand not wanting like enclaves like
smaller I would like the like Midwest like smaller places to
be a melting pot but
but like big cities I don't know why you wouldn't expect it to
be multicultural to have these like big things celebrating like
certain groups of people who live there as long as the people
share the city and they don't have values that that conflict
with American values why is it a problem >> that I I don't
see anyone >> Oh dude I've I've done these these parades
and all the time Like I I I am not a fan of like any of these
Puerto Rican day parade. I've made jokes on that [__]
because they're Americans. What the [__] are they
doing? Nobody cares about
like and this is kind of >> So is that them asserting dominance
>> to a degree? Yeah, for sure. >> So it's the same
thing. >> Yes. Yes. That that is that is a form of them
asserting dominance to a degree. And I I'm not a fan of it. Like
I think we need to go back to >> the funny thing is is
like my says, oh well they're allowed to do it in in Islamic
countries or whatever. It's like yeah because that's that's the
values they have there is they should be asserting dominance
over the people. They shouldn't be letting them have liberty.
Like liberty leads to degeneracy. These are like their beliefs.
Those aren't American beliefs.
Don't try to force Don't try to force them. You're like Byron
is in fact doing what he is arguing against. He's trying to enforce
like an an Islamic or Middle Eastern or more just in general
like conservative worldview on a country that explicitly rejects
it. >> So hardcore nationalism, America only one flag policy.
None of this flag >> Yeah, like one flag America flag.
What about freedom of speech? That doesn't make sense. Like >> Yeah.
Like you're literally you're trying to infl enforce values in
the United States that aren't a part of the United States core
value structure. Like you are doing the thing you're complaining
about. >> Freedom of expression is the core thing. >> Of
course, of course, of course. But I think having parades is now.
>> So Sneo Sneo totally just destroying him now because
Byron's decided that he's going to Yeah. Christian Sharia or
it's not even Christian Sharia. It's like red pill Sharia. Like
what the are you talking about? You're you're advocating for
a bunch of things that don't make any sense.
That's Christian nationalism is definitionally anti-American.
Uh there's different types of So yeah, like Fuentes
um Fuentes and Big Papa fascist, these people would 100% be anti-American
values, right? They think that like the liberty provided to Americans
is actually causing harm to Americans and they need to they need
to curb that, right? I don't I don't know if all nationalism
is that way or all Christian nationalism would be that way. Like
Christian nationalism would be curbing religious freedoms obviously,
but I don't know if it would be totally against all freedom of
uh expression. It would just be probably curbing religious freedom.
I don't know. It seems like slightly different to me, but the
the primary people who who preach Christian nationalism, Fuentes,
BPF, some of these guys, yeah, I think it's fundamentally
>> Rage is part of speech. It is a part of speech, but
I don't think I don't like I
>> um I I'm sorry. I think it's maybe more deeply more
deeply anti-American, more like fundamentally anti-American.
Yeah. >> Don't think Look, you should be able to freely
express yourself to a degree, but when we're sanctioning
to a degree, yes. >> So, what's the degree? >> The
degree is once it starts to interfere with American >> I
swear to God if Sneo starts cooking them on the same point like
Myron, why are you advocating for like Muslim values, Musl Muslim
cultural values in America? How about you chill and let them
have their American values, bro? Why are you trying to bring
Sharia here, >> Nationalism, I think that's that's when
you start running into problems because we have the no more free
speech. >> We don't have No, no, we have free speech. But
>> you're saying we we shouldn't. >> No, no. I'm
saying we have free speech, but obviously it's there's always
limits on free speech, right? Like for example, you can't run.
You can't run into a theater and say, "Well, that's free speech
absolutism." You can't run into a theater and say, "Fire, that's
free speech absolutism, right?" I would say, >> "Okay,
but you have to have that's fine because there's a direct harm.
There's a direct traceable harm, right? And there's a direct
traceable harm that is not equal to somebody preaching their
religion. You could say there's a harm in like the religion
existing there, right? But then you have to be able to argue
that's a it's a harm greater than any other religion. >> Hey,
we want to have free speechment of violence maximalism.
>> Incitement of violence is I think is a fair thing to
exclude from that. But parades aren't incitement of violence.
It's a celebration. It's it's it's an it's a it's an incitement
to nationalism of another country that quite frankly >> and
that that's against free speech. >> I'm not going to say
it's against free speech. I think you should be able to do it
to a degree, but once you're shutting off streets, right, to
to >> when we were praying at town square, we didn't shut
off the street, >> right? The streets are still open. >> You're
impeding people. >> Nobody was impeded. >> They can't
walk in front of you when you pray. You and I know that you can't
walk in front of them in front of that area in front of the stairs.
>> They they could walk in front like that other street
across. Why did Why did y'all pray like somewhere else not in
Time Square? >> We wouldn't have fit there for >> Why
not pray at a mosque? There's plenty of mosques in >> Wait,
why wouldn't they pray in time in Times Square if they could
get a permit? I assume this was a legal thing, a legal demonstration,
right? I assume they got a permit for Ramadan at Times Square
and they were like, "Oh yeah, the city of New York allows this.
They want it."
Like they don't they don't just go do it every day. It's not
like an everyday thing where they they congest Time Square. Yeah,
but Byron didn't consent. It's like it's so stupid. It's like
goes through all of the legal just all the legal things to go
do this demonstration and it's only about a thing that is core
a core tenant of Americanism, freedom of expression, freedom
of religion.
What? What? What are we complaining about in New York City? All
over. >> This is the first time for everybody to come together
from all over the city. They all came there. I don't We wouldn't
fit in a mosque. There was too many >> bro. Pray pray at
a mosque. Like, pray in a mosque. >> We wouldn't be able
to fit. >> I I think I I truly do think we need to bring
patriotism back. We need to bring back nationalism back. And
I >> Yeah, but you don't do that by curbing.
There's no way. You can't literally be like, okay, well, the
beatings will continue until morale improves. That's that's also
fundamentally anti-American. You can't just get rid of every
other option and go, you have to love America. No, you can't
love any other place. You have to love America. How about you
teach people why America's awesome, teach them to love America.
You bring back nationalism by showing how awesome your country
is by doing awesome [__] as a country. How about
that?
which is literally the way patriotism first got started in America.
Americans did cool.
They're like, "Oh yeah, we went to the moon. We put a flag on
the moon. That's awesome.
Do that happening in time." See, you're upset about like praying
in public. What else happening in Time Square at the time? Like
Mickey Mouse, Elmo, drug deals, fights. >> Yeah, of course.
>> But are we awesome anymore? Uh, yeah. America is still
awesome in like all of the same ways. It's literally still like
the same place. It's still got every possible advantage. It will
still be the greatest country on earth bar like apocalypse happening,
right?
Sorry. That's how it is. >> Like it's just stupid like
rappers selling CDs. It's not like the alternative to what else
is happening in Time Square besides praying is it was like okay
were we really interrupting anything important? No. No. Only
thing we stopped was a couple drug deals and Elmo and gorillas.
>> No, man. Because here's the thing. Police got to go
>> uh part of the Canada shares a lot of the same advantages
that the US does, right? that it's got two giant oceans around
it. No major like strategic enemies like all that close, right?
Like they're all separated by oceans. I guess you could argue
Russia is pretty close to Alaska, but that's America, right?
That's that's America's got that locked down. So Canada's got
all the same advantages. Canada has the St. Lawrence, that whole
basin where a bunch of the like a bunch of those major metropolises
exist on on Canada's side as well.
It's like the same same
the the fates of these two countries are totally interlin. You
guys like try to you guys try to get mad. You guys try to talk
Canada. Beta the countries are just totally interlin. All right.
Everything about Canada will like no matter how much America
wins or loses, Canada just gets dragged along. And if Canada's
ever losing for some reason, it's going to drag America down
with it, right? It's just they're totally interlin.
You can't talk Canada without talking the United States. Good
luck. >> Go out there. >> There was no cops.
We had no cops. >> Nothing. It was just us completely >> I
still I still >> and it wasn't sanctioned by the city.
We just showed up. >> I again I think right when you're
praying and you're disrupting other once your prayer and your
uh worship starts to disrupt other >> drug deals in Elmo
still disrupting like it's still disrupting like I I get what
you're saying that the okay drug deals in Elmo but also families
that might have wanted to walk in that area. people that might
have wanted
now they're being now they got to listen to you guys pray out
loud like and this is what I'm trying >> 20 minutes >> I
have to hear this really annoying for 20 minutes get them out
of here >> that's like yelling fire in a crowded theater
okay the second they started praying people started fleeing time
square all right there was a there was a mass trampling event
>> it's still disrupting man >> okay disrup there's
parades happen all the time is like y'all could just pray in
a mosque pray in the mosque like why does everyone have to and
>> we do pray in a mosque too >> yeah but Pray in
the mosque. Just pray in the mosque only. Like don't why do you
guys got to pray out loud like out in front of everybody? >> I
mean it's just it's a display of culture and like what about
the Hari Krishna? Every park in New York City if you go to Wash
Square Park Central Park you'll see all these bald white people
when they have the the monk outfits on. They're like bang Har
Krishna banging the drum. I see that every single day in the
train stations in the park. They do it loudly in public. Like
it's like it's not it's not a big deal. I just see them. I'm
like hey what's going on? And they're like hey and they offer
you a book. And you're
>> How do these keep losing debates to the guy who scored
95 on an internet IQ test? Bro, I honest to God, if you tested
Big Papa, a fascist,
Andrew Wilson, I don't think Andrew Wilson would score that high.
If you work hard at something, debate is not really an intelligence
test. I'm sorry. People think it is. It isn't. It's like got
an intelligence floor that is very low, very reachable, and you
can be as good as as anyone else at debate. Okay, debate is about
learning exactly where to go, like what direction to go in for
a specific argument, learning the dialogue trees, and then being
able to flow between them. There's nothing preventing somebody
who is, I guess, 95 IQ. I tend to think Sneak's higher, right?
But, um, there's nothing preventing someone like him from doing
well in debate.
This isn't exactly a hard debate. It's not, but I'm telling you
that like a level of like abstract intelligence, a super high
level of abstract intelligence isn't required to win debates.
Darius can do it. Yeah, Darius can do it, too. All it takes is
the like effort effort required to go and think about these dialogue
trees, think about how you flow between them and and learn where
to go with any given argument cuz most of these arguments have
been done to death and you could just argue people down this
exact dialogue tree and win a debate, right? Like Sneo, I guarantee
you Sneo's watched Muhammad Hijab or somebody else have a bunch
of the debates that he's won, right? that debate with Charlie.
I guarantee you watched essentially every point he made there
get made by Muhammad Hijab and he's just remembered exactly how
you put those those answers together right now. Maybe not for
the Americanism one. I don't know who you would have talked to
about this one, but he could have watched debates online. There's
anything he could have done, right? You're used to it cuz you're
like in New York City. You're around these all the time. Like
my thing is is I think once your worship starts to get to a point
where you're disrupting other people, I think that's a problem,
right? Especially when >> nobody complains. Yeah, they
don't complain cuz they don't want to be called. This is this
is a very bro you got to remember no one's going to complain
because this is a controversial take. Like not a lot of people
are willing to sit there and say, "Bro, you probably shouldn't
be praying." And I get attacked for it. As a Muslim guy, I can
only imagine someone that's not Muslim saying like, "Oh, getting
attacked, being called Islamophobic, whatever. How is it most
people are scared?" >> It's a It's a public space. Like,
so you can do that. You could break. So, look, public spaces
you can play your phone speaker. You can do drug deals. You can
you What about is the gorilla who takes up space? Is he disrupting
people from walking on that side of sidewalk? I I don't I don't
understand this. >> I I don't think it's appropriate as
1 to 2% of the population to be openly% of the population is
what Muslims are about 1.5 to 2% of the population in America.
>> Minority when people say Islamic >> No, that's
a lie. That's a scam. I agree with you. I agree with you. There's
not a Muslim takeover. It's really a takeover because they're
a minority. We don't have the same representation in government.
Whatever. What I'm saying is as a guest, right? Because we are
we are guests here. I think >> what does that mean? Guests.
>> We're guests. This is not a Muslim country. This is
not a Muslim country. >> Oh, then you could make an argument
that's a country if they control 98% of the politician. >> This
guy means it's a it's a freedom of religion country.
>> That's that's such a great point. Not because it's like
not because it's true. It's because Myron agrees with it and
Myron has to like totally kneel on that point. And so Myron just
goes, "Ah, come on, man." Right? He if you're talking about influence
only, Myron totally believes that control everything. So he has
to like he he knows he loses on that point. So he just goes,
"Ah, come on,
>> It's like it's like a bad point, but for Sneo, it's
a great point to make in this exact situation. >> It's
a secular country. Okay. What do you mean we're guessing? I'm
a citizen here. I'm not a guest. Wait, no, no, no. [laughter]
Hold on. I'm not a guest. I have a passport. I was born here.
Of course. What I'm saying is But I'm saying Islamic faith. The
Islam is of course it's your country. But what I'm saying is
that the Islamic >> It's not your country, Myin. Why are
you Myin Myin? What country were you born in? Iron >> faith
is not a part of the American >> Neither is Christianity.
>> It's not it. This country was founded by >> But
it's not part of the American >> The people that founded
this country, >> it's not it's not in the doctrine. Just
because of >> Myron might have been born in America, too.
I thought he was Sudin.
>> That's my bad. It looks like he was born in Brooklyn.
Okay. My bad, Myin. You're an American. >> State was put
in place so that either would not corrupt each other, but it's
still a Christian country founded by Christian people, right?
Cuz you can make the argument. You can make the argument like
Syria wasn't a Muslim country isn't a Muslim country because
All right, I got to back it up. I got to back it up. >> State
was put in place so that either would not corrupt each other.
But >> okay, you work for the No, he he is born in America.
I thought I totally thought somehow that he um that he was from
Sudan and he moved here that there's some reason I think that
based on on some content I watched before, but I I don't remember
exactly. >> Question not in the doctrine. Just because
separation of church and state was put in place so that either
would not corrupt each other. Uh, I don't particularly notice
Kger unless chat's being funny. Talking about how like wild the
chat is is something only complete morons do. Trying to go, "Oh,
a chat says this, the chat." Dude, he's not nobody's watching
the chat. It has nothing to do with the content. You'd have to
be a total to get obsessed over the chat when like uh when like
when they're not doing anything to interact with it, right? You
you can do it if you want to like make fun of specific people,
right? Like if you want to go Nick Waffin SS. Oh, this guy looks
like a total. But like I don't think it says anything about the
content. But it's still a Christian country founded by Christian
people, right? >> I I don't think it says anything about
my either. You can make the argument. >> You can make the
argument like Syria wasn't a Muslim country isn't a Muslim country
because Bashar Assad was a sec was a secularist or Saddam Hussein
was a secularist. It's still a Muslim country majority and they're
going to play that. I'll say that. Yeah, it's a Christian majority
country, but it's not a Christian country by definition. >> I
think this is a Christian country, >> but there's no there's
no paperwork or any like it's not in the constitution. It was
it was found. It's not a Well, they they have got him. >> Even
when you pledge allegiance as an American, I grew up >> pledge
allegiance saying by God the
>> Oh, hold on. Um Cherry brought this up earlier. She
gave me the link. Pledge of Allegiance was written in 1892 by
Baptist Minister Francis Bellamy. It was originally published
in the Youth's Companion on September 8th, 1982. Bellamy had
hoped that the pledge would be used by citizens in any country.
Oh, so he I pledge allegiance to my flag and the republic for
uh for which it stands one nation indivisible with liberty and
justice for all. This is the original pledge of allegiance. Okay,
this is what it was this is how it was written. 1923 the words
the flag of the United States of America were added at the time
this time it uh it read I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the republic for which it stands
one nation indivisible with liberty and justice for all. And
then in
in response to the communist threat of the times, President Eisenhower
encouraged Congress to add the words under God, creating a 31-word
pledge we say today, or the 31-word pledge we say today. Today
it reads, I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States
of America and the republic for which it stands, one nation under
God, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all. It's literally
an anti- Red Scare thing.
It's like a Sorry, not anti. It's like a Red Scare thing. It's
over communism. It wasn't even there. It's not a part of the
founding. It's not a part of how it was originally developed.
Yeah. Under God. Doesn't even specify one God. Yeah. Okay. Easy.
Easy. God is mentioned in >> You say Jesus. They believe.
>> You say God. >> You don't say Jesus. >> You
say God. You don't have to say Jesus cuz the Holy Spirit >> to
them. God God and Jesus are synonymous.
Synonymous. >> Yes and no. Actually, if you talk to a >> it
depends on who you talk. Oh,
but also beyond that,
I think you just have to look at the the history of it to know
that this is like
this isn't even a good point for minor to make because it wasn't
originally developed that way. And it wasn't done that way to
keep it wasn't done that way to
fight, you know, a Muslim religion or any other religion or any
other like aspect. It wasn't had nothing to do with religion.
is to fight another ideology, one that people think is sort of
>> Yeah. Being honest, bro.
>> They look at they look at God and Jesus is the same.
Like he's the son of God. >> He's also God's only begotten
son. So they are separate. >> It depends on who you look
at or who who you
that's a different conversation. But the reason that this is
>> Oh, that's not what that means. >> God we trust
is because it's the most universal statement. >> Yes. But
the point I'm trying to make is is that >> I that's Trinity
stuff. I'm I'm I'm going to stay away from >> regardless.
This country was founded by Christians. They reserve the right
to run the country however they want. And if they do want to
play church, I take it a step further. If they want to play the
church bells, I think they can because this is a Christian country.
Just like in a Muslim country, if they want to play that dance
10 times a day, you got to shut up and take it.
>> Yeah. But that's the that's because the values of the
Muslim country. Stop trying to bring those values to America.
>> If it's a Christian country, then why do you not support
Israel? Doesn't the Bible for evangelical Christians say God
blesses those who bless the state of Israel? Because we know
that we know that evangelicals is is cap. >> Okay. Well,
I mean, it was it was >> well, it's the Isn't that the
majority of I thought No, hold on. Catholicism would be a bigger
chunk than evangelicalism, right? But evangelical Christians
make up a huge chunk of this country of of America. What do you
mean evangelicals are cap? That's such a He's just been arguing
that, oh, it's a Christian founded country. Isn't Isn't that
like the largest Protestant group? Wasn't it a Protestant Christian
country? a white Protestant country when it was founded by what
do you mean evangelicals the largest group of those Protestants
are cap
huh >> founded by Protestant Christians that's what Protestants
believe if you're if you're following your logic that you >> yeah
hold on
oh Sneo's about to make my go oh we uh we love the they're special
but about to become a Islamic Zionist right now >> you
want to be a patriot and a national >> Myron just got totally
Myron
dude sne thinko is actually doing some crazy judo right now and
I say judo intentionally
then you should support Israel >> actually protestants
don't really with uh what's his name the in their lies by um
who who wrote the who was he who was the head of the pro the
who was he who was the founder of Protestantism um something
Luther >> Martin Luther
>> the Lutheran church
>> it is Martin Luther isn't it >> um I think it
was Martin Luther dude only image Christians like
the Jews in say it >> by um who who wrote the who was he
who was the head of the pro the who was he who's the founder
of Protestantism um something Luther Martin Luther >> no
um I think >> no no sne Martin Luther >> yeah [laughter]
>> dude only evangelical Christians like observe Israel
as like real everyone else like all real Christians like Catholics
Orthodox Christians >> what do Protestants think >> they
don't [__] with you either they >> this is
the dumbest debate I've ever heard my better at debate than this.
Uh, actually all the realist ninjas say it this way. Think this
point are you making, bro? How about you cite anything? How about
you act actually like grab some fact of reality and use it? Don't
just say, "Oh, well, the real ones think it's this way." That's
not debate.
>> They don't say, "God bless the state of >> No,
that's just evangelical. >> Okay, so what >> Scoffield
Bible reader, but most Christians are are that aren't read, right?
And remember, this is just American Christians. Christians all
over the place don't. If you look at Eastern Europe, they're
all super anti-Semitic. >> Why are you bringing up Eastern
Europe, bro? Who the cares about the Orthodox
>> They're real.
>> Orthodox Christians are super uh anti-Semitic. Shout
out to them. >> Yeah, but like they don't with the
Let me just >> Okay. Do you think Hold on.
Orthodox Christians are literally
Okay. Now I think I think the Catholic Church and the Eastern
Orthodox Church have come to some kind of dant, right? But like
when you think about it, Orthodox Christians or like Eastern
Orthodoxy has to be some kind of schism, right? Like it has to
be thought of by other Christian groups as a schism if it's if
the country is founded by Protestant Christians. Why wouldn't
Eastern Orthodoxy, a schism of their own religion, be looked
down upon more than smaller minority religions in their
>> Just say that cuz anti-semitism is a fake word. It it
but it's your it's your mentality approaching thinking that that
we're guests here. >> Yeah, I think we're guests here.
That is that is >> we were my my we were born here. >> No,
the Islamic faith and the the religion of Islam. You are a guest
as a Muslim in the United States. >> I'm not a guest in
my home, >> bro. We are guests here. >> What do you
We were >> We are guests here. >> We were born here.
>> Yes. But are >> Dude, what the Reuben Ruben? Hold
on. What? Who made this?
That's a crazy thing to make. That's an in
I shame on you, Ruben Rubin. Totally disavow this. Why would
you put this in my Discord?
That's That's just disgusting. Okay, that's just gross.
Thank you, Reven Ruben. That's really That's really disappointing,
dude. I I thought you're better than that. >> Our religion.
Our our religion. >> So now your faith makes you a guest.
>> Yes. If you're going to open Yes. To a degree. Yes.
>> To a degree or
because obviously everything is like nuance. Like nothing is
absolute. But like the point I'm trying to make is is that >> dude
Sneo's like Sneo's actually little broing Myron so hard right
now. Like to a degree. You want to make an actual claim here,
buddy? He's obviously been I think Sneo's just been in those
like hardcore Muslim debate circles for so long that he's actually
gotten good at >> The Islamic faith has this is not a Muslim
country. So therefore, >> what about Catholics? Are Catholics
because it was it was founded by >> I would say they're
closer to >> So they're still guess. >> I would say
they're because here's the thing with Catholic. I I feel like
there's absolutely an argument that schisms in the same religion
are are more looked down upon. Hey, what do you think who do
you think is more accepted in like a primary a primary um Sunni
country? Like a tiny minority of Christians or a big big chunk
of Shia Muslims, right?
The answer to that is obvious. That's that group's a threat.
Suddenly that group's a problem. >> Uh Catholicism, Christianity,
all of it. It's it's all it's all kind of one. And I look at
them all as the same like they >> Hold on.
>> Yo, Harat, thank you for the five gifted. Let's go.
>> Let's go. Let's go. We uh What do we got here? We got
five.
Oh, this puts us at what? So, we need five subs, I think. Five
more subs for another two hours on the stream, guys. Let's get
those five subs in. All right. Five subs or $25 for another two
hours in the stream. Let's go. >> Thank you very much.
They disagree with each otherally,
but I would say that >> a lot of them say that that each
other >> if they believe in Christ, they're a Christian
to a degree. What denomination isn't really as relevant is if
they believe in Jesus as their Lord and Savior, that makes them
a Christian. >> The Protestants criticize the Catholics
for praying to Mary. >> See, that's that's arguments within
themselves. But in general, they're all Christians because they
all believe in Jesus. There's different
for example, right? There's there's uh Sunnis and there's Shia,
but we don't look at them differently with our our faith. Honestly,
we really don't. They pray in the same mosque. They do some funny
[__] praying on that's not all >> but they
pray in the same mosque in >> sometimes there's some [__]
mosque but >> but they can pray alongside they're not considered
they're not considered kufu they're not considered cafes they're
they're just misguided as soon as >> by logic then only
protestant Christians should be the non- guests in America if
it was founded by Protestant Christians >> no because they're
all Christians I look at them all as Christians denominations
this is literally why the the whole separation of church and
state was a thing was because was to avoid that problem fights
between themselves so they literally instructed that in place
to deal with that very problem you're talking about which is
like the different sect in Christianity. Okay. >> That's
why they >> if that's all it was why is that not specified
anywhere? Are are the are are the people who wrote the federalist
papers are the founders like morons who just constantly forget
about stuff? I I don't think so. Seems like if they just wanted
to be amongst Christians they just say that somewhere anywhere.
Literally anywhere. My why do you think you know better than
the founders? >> Separate. That's why the separate >> you
ever heard of textualism bro? >> Separation of church state
was instilled. was to keep Baptists, Protestants, Catholics,
and all these other guys from fighting each other because this
is the problem that they had in England with the Catholic Church
and everything. >> So, you believe we're guests in our
own country? And >> I believe as Muslims, we are guests
in America. Yes. Because because America is not a Muslim country.
>> Hold on. This is actually a great point, Major Dr. Gastly.
I've not been keeping
>> But has Byron actually said something that he hasn't
immediately gone, "Oh, well, maybe not." He's he's literally
he's become Sneo. He is like like Sneo has reversed the Sneo
aura onto Myron. Myin is the new Sneo.
Sneak's like literally making Myron retract every single thing
he says over and over and over again. And then he's like smirking
over here. He's like smirking at how poorly Myron's doing. He's
like he's making him seem like a complete [__] idiot.
My needs a father to guide him through this. Does anybody have
Andrew Tate on speed dial? I think Andrew Tate needs to give
Myron a pep talk. All
>> Andrew on the phone. like Egypt, like Sudan, like UAE,
like Qatar. These are Muslim countries. When we go there, we
respect and we don't say a word. When we were in Dubai, we had
Jalab.
>> That's a that's a value. Those those countries actually
enforce that. In a lot of ways, >> we I spoke Arabic whenever
I had a chance, right? We assimilated. We respected that culture,
right? As as even the first time before you diverted, we respected
that culture cuz we understood we are guests there. I think Muslims
need to exercise the same thing in United States. >> Yeah,
I know. Cuz we're vis we're literally visiting Dubai. I was born
here. Like what do you >> Yeah, but the Islamic faith we're
American citizens, but the Islamic faith is not is not >> there's
nothing I mean you're just making up America like >> we're
1% of the population that that in itself proves that this is
not you can single out anybody and say that they're a minority
to some extent. You it's not you don't need to describe somebody
just by their faith. You could say that your skin color is or
where you're from or >> when we're talking about people
have glasses here's the thing we're here's the thing Hindus
Muslims we're all guests in America being honest.
Okay.
So, religion wouldn't include paganism. Maybe, but it seems like
Sneo already said Thomas Jefferson named out named some other
Abrahamic faiths.
>> All are not I'm not just saying this is as Muslims were
guess. I think >> what about minorities? Are minorities
guess in America? >> Uh like what do you mean minorities
like blacks and [__] like that or not? >> Anybody
not white? >> Yeah. I mean I would say yeah >> we're
also guess. >> Yeah. White people built and founded this
country. Bro, we're all guests >> Okay. the only so America
is is entitled to white Christians only. They're the only non-
guests here. Do you have to be to be a true American? >> It's
so funny that we actually discussed something adjacent to this
topic with the Asmin Gold clip right off the bat. Right. That's
kind of funny. >> Like we know that culturally America
is not like this. They've literally amended their constitution
which is the only case where you like kind of go beyond the founders
when you actually amend the constitution to say this is no longer
commensurate with our values. We have to update our values. Right?
That becomes the new American value. Wait,
America. 0.1% of Americans have Down syndrome. They're just visiting.
Oh, sorry. I clicked the wrong thing, too. I was clicking on
this. I don't Does that count as like how different would that
be from race? Is it not weird that you you distinguish people
on genetics, but you don't really distinguish down pe downs people
into like something that's akin to race, even though it's basically
kind of like a it's like a genetic difference. I don't know.
It's I guess it's that it's not a phenotype. I suppose you to
be a white person. >> I never said that. I I never said
everyone else is not a guest. >> We are We are Americans,
but we are guests here because we did not found this country.
We're Americans, but like we're not >> That's a good point,
J. Every race has them. Wait, but do they Hold on. Do they? I've
never seen a I don't think I've ever seen a black person with
Down
>> Yeah. No, I believe they do. I believe there are down
syndrome people in every race or whatever, but I I'm saying I've
never seen it. Google it. No, I'm good. the I guess original
Americans. >> Okay. So, what about Europe? >> No,
I've definitely seen Asians with Down syndrome. I've 100% seen
Asians with Down syndrome. >> Europeans like people with
two second generation Europeans who came here. >> Well,
I'm talking about like the people here that like their families
been here for generations for the Revolutionary Wars, whatever.
>> Okay. So, if if I'm a white guy and my parents immigrated
here uh after World War II and I'm a white Christian and my parents
are from Germany, right? >> And you came here after World
War II. >> Am I a guest? I would say from a framer's perspective
if you came like you were here in the 1700s like like if you
have lineage back to like the colonial individuals. >> What
is that like 5% of the country? >> Probably not as much.
Yeah. I mean >> So everyone's a guest here. >> A
lot. Yeah. >> So whose country is it? It's just those 5%
of people. >> I would say it's a America is a white majority
Christian country and we are guests here. Yeah. That's what I
would >> So So the only So 95% of people here are >> I
love I love that is like doing back flips to try to follow like
what Fuentes and some other people believe. like Fentes, Andrew
Wilson, what they argue. He's doing actual back flips to make
this argument.
I could believe that you could say like you could talk about
founding stock, how the country was founded, what it had in mind.
And I would almost believe that they maybe meant Christians or
or Christian like um religions. But I would say if the if if
religion comes to mean all religion and not just of Christianity
or of like uh some Abrahamic faith like uh some Judeo-Christian
thing. Even if if religion comes to mean everything, right? Every
religion and the constitution is never updated. I do think there's
like some argument for people really want it to keep meaning
what it means now to everyone, right?
And now that I now that I say this out loud, this seems to be
the exact thing of like originalism, right? And textualism versus
like interpreting like interpreting the the constitution for
like modern values, right?
Like this is actually the primary way that Supreme Court justices
like disagree on interpreting law nowadays. Yeah. With the immigration.
Yeah. Yeah. You're right. Yeah. 95% of people. >> A lot
of them. Yeah. A lot of them are >> Okay. So then, >> and
this is why we have a lot of the problems we have because we
have all these people coming in, bringing their cultures, not
assimilating, not learning language. Like New York City, I'll
give you an example. New York City is a perfect example. New
York City is the definition of a melting pot. You got people
from the Caribbean, from Africa. It's always been that way. From
Yeah. >> since like the 40s predominantly, >> it's
it's been Yeah. But it's always even more so now >> with
the Ellis Island, the turn of the century, it's always of course.
And it's always the Statue of Liberty, give us your week and
whatever. Cool. Whatever. But the point I'm trying to make is
is like New York City is a perfect example of like why this multiculturalism,
mass multiculturalism doesn't work a lot of the time. Like I
think New York City is a failed city. >> It's really safe.
It's it's been this is the least amount of crime we've had in
a >> Bro,
[clears throat] that's fine. But how is it a failed city? It's
a great >> It's a failed city, bro. >> What do you
But based on what >> I think it's a failed city. Um crime
metrics, uh dirtiness, cost of living has been going through
the roof as as uh the decades pass. I think New York City is
a failed city, bro. And I think >> so when was New York
City >> and if if it were and if it were not for its you
know historic and um you know premier position as a major city
in the United States it would be degradated even further. >> So
when was New York not failed? In the 70s there were prostitutes
all over time square. Drugs were worse. Crime was worse. Giuliani
did you know fix a lot of that stuff. >> Juliani did fix
a lot. >> The '90s was actually the most uh 1990 was the
most murders. >> Okay. The mafia was running it in the
in the ' 50s. >> So it was by that it was failed then.
>> Uh I think it was better than it is now. Yeah. Okay.
>> I think it was I think it was better than because here's
the thing, right? So, here's the difference. When the mafia was
running things and they were involved in crime or whatever, they
were each other, right? They were like each other like other
made guys, hey, you have a problem with this family, whatever.
Yeah, the violence sucked and everything else like that. But
it isn't like now like now it's it's worse cuz you're like getting
Well, the '7s was the worst decade by the way, for crime. But
I think New York City has gotten worse as it's become more and
more of a multi bro mass immigration in itself has creates a
lot of problems. >> Yeah, that's true. >> Yeah. So
I I I think and and New York City is like a beautiful personification
of that. Yeah. But massive creates >> People people say
that and then they go visit New York and >> so so like
us having this majority of guests is actually created us created
a lot of problems for us because now everyone's like me and you
learn English language like assimilate to the culture respect
the culture. >> Should the American guest like who should
be deported from America? Um >> people that are here illegally.
Uh that yeah people that are here illegally. Yeah. What about
the people in Dearborn playing, you know, the Adon? >> Didn't
uh didn't Myin try to get Pixie's like wife deported? Wasn't
Myin like trying to actually fed post directly?
Isn't that something he did? Am I Am I
I was told this, but I didn't see it. I didn't see any of the
tweets. So,
dude, Myron's a [__] snitch.
That's crazy.
Pixie goes on your show, she helps you out, and you you're straight
up snitching on her. trying to get people to like actually call
the call ICE on her. Well, yeah. No, it's Destiny and him. Both
of them, right? >> Should they be deported? >> Um,
if they're here illegally. Yeah. >> Yeah. I saw the post
about it. I saw the post about it and then that's getting added
to the lawsuit or something.
I just can't imagine like I Where's Rise? Why doesn't Rise make
a post of like Not So, Erdite and Connor like sitting at a table
calmly debating like why they still stand beside Destiny while
Destiny sitting there with like a chainsaw like cutting Pixie
in half. Right. They both pretend they like care. They want to
be like decent people. And Pixie is just getting like chainsawed
in half and they're like pretending they don't see it. There's
just like blood and gore hitting them in the face and they just
pretend they don't see it. They're like, "I don't know about
that. I don't know. I don't know what's going on over there."
Yeah. How I What I don't understand is how the do people say
they could be friends with both of them? I That's as far as I
know. Like a position. I'm friends with both of them.
e you have to either either one of them's like a horrifying liar,
right? You can't you can't have it both ways. They're both saying
that the other one's lying. The other one's a total psychopath
destroying the other person's life. You can't you can't walk
both lines there.
Lying easy. That's what I think. Yes. But it's just very funny
that I I don't see condemnation for any of the conduct from any
of the from any of them.
Um, and that's really all that gets interesting now is just watching
how far these people can go before they break. So, >> if
they're here illegally. Yeah. Um, but my thing is like I don't
think it's fair to the other residents of Dearborn to play the
Dan multiple times a day just because you enjoy a slight majority.
It's only like 50 60. >> The worst part is Ardite saying
at the beginning that she would keep working with Destiny if
he showed remorse. What you don't understand I could go is that
Cleman and I were very mean to Arrodite. All right. And she didn't
account for that when she stated her principle that like Destiny
would have to show remorse. She didn't account for people being
mean to her. And after people were mean to her, that changed
everything.
Kind of sounds like somebody else, right? Like a certain Cyprian
Greek fellow who may live in Australia who decides that his morals
change with the wind based on anybody being mad with him. Feel
like there's a lot of parallels between these two people that
nobody's really explored yet.
>> Muslim majority there. And well, excuse me, let me rephrase.
It's 50 60% Arabs and people from North Africa, which you can
assume 90% of them are going to be Muslims. So you can assume
that it's a slight majority. I don't think it's fair to the other
40% in the United States that they have to deal with listening
to five times a day. >> I don't think that's fair. >> Yeah.
I mean, just just to go back to >> because I truly don't
think America is a Muslim country and that's we don't have the
numbers to even represent, >> but it's also not a Christian.
It's not a Christian country. It's just not. >> I think
it's a Christian and we could we could disagree, but it's not
in the Constitution. You don't have to say it to become a citizen.
You don't need to declare it. There's freedom of religion insult.
Like that's the the if you're actually going to talk about what
it means to be an American. If you look at the amendments and
you look at the the rights that we have, it has nothing to do
with being a Christian. Again, just >> you forgot Hutch
is in that category, too. Um, is he? I don't see Hutch in that
category, but maybe. I don't I haven't seen Hutch in that category
personally. I'd listen to an argument for like that he would
be in that category. I don't see it personally.
So,
woo drew and who based >> that's not in the constitution
so to speak, right? Um or maybe even the bill of rights or whatever
does not >> any of the >> well and they probably
did that >> to be honest. I shouldn't even disagree with
you substance because none of like nobody around Hutch would
ever ever correct that for me after reading the chat. Right.
So like I should just let anybody who says that I should let
them maintain those negative opinions. I should never state like
anything positive in their direction cuz h
it's like not worth it to even have friction with your chat at
this point. It's so silly. >> And they probably did that
on purpose, right? To >> to not declare it as I know that's
how I know that's how nothing gets better and that's why I say
it in a venting moment and then I end up still doing it later
on anyway. >> It's a single religion this country. That's
the whole reason he did that. So I'm going to follow what the
founding father said. >> Yeah. Yeah. But here's the thing.
America does have an identity whether people want to accept it
or not. And this is where we can have the >> dis what's
the identity? >> The American identity as a majority white
country that's a Christian nation. That is the American identity
unfortunately. And I'll give you an example of this. If you go
to Japan or uh China or whatever and you envision an American,
what are they going to envision right now? At least now they're
going to envision or at least historically before the mass immigration
a Caucasian individual eating a hamburger that's fat. That's
what they think of Americans. Hillbilly, whatever the [__]
it may be. That's what people think of. That's and and that is
the identity of America. that that's what it >> A fat hillbilly,
but not a >> Well, that's Well, I'm saying the stereotype.
That's how they would stereotype it. But like they would envision
a Caucasian
American with an American accent, whatever. Like if you're trying
to have the American uh what's the word I want to use here? Like
um emblem, right? Like if you went to a country, you say you
you need someone to like be able to identify something, right?
Off without saying a word. What would you use? You would use
a white person with some Jords, a cowboy hat, right? Uh maybe
an American flag and be like, "Okay, what is this person?" an
American, right? That's what they would think, right? Versus
if they gave me and you, it would be harder for them because
they would be like, uh, I don't I don't know. We'd maybe have
to speak English. These these are the things they'd have to like
figure out. They'd have >> It's so funny that like I feel
like I don't know about Myin, but I could overcome so many of
these racist people by just asking like I
the the Roman Empire already solved this problem, right? As you
grow, as your country changes, you incorporate new groups. Like
yes, these groups do move up the ranks. They do become equal.
Your identity changes over time. If it doesn't, you just ferment
like rebellion. You ferment destruction. You you will go towards
your own destruction. Like as you start to take over the world,
become the the center of power, the best people from different
places will flock to the the heart of the empire, right? Will
flock to. And it's not quite the same in in the UK because doesn't
explicitly control any of these other places, right? But it's
like pretty much everybody who likes Rome, what happened when
Rome stopped doing that effectively? Oh, which happened when
Rome stopped doing that effectively? Yeah, I'm sure it did. But
like when you think about the golden age of Rome, that happened
under dudes from Spain.
Those were Spanish emperors of Rome, right? Those people were
born in
That was the golden age of the Roman Empire where people born
not in Italy. The Roman emperor is born not in Italy, right?
So like if you think the Roman Empire is cool, if you think that
empire that lasted so long that took over most of the known world
at that point was cool. If you think that's awesome, there's
a way to do it and you can't you can't deny it. Okay. It involves
like letting people of different ethnicities in like incorporate
and join your empire and become citizens over time. That's basically,
by the way, Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But the funny thing is, hold on.
I can't click on BB Poison's message cuz I actually agree. The
funny thing is America like incorporated this 100%. Right? Every
ethnic group that comes to America, they face some kind of like
basically people sort of like look down on them. I it's different
with black people because of how they came to America, right?
But with like all of the different groups, Italians, Irish, all
these people who came over, they were like looked down upon majorly
for a time, right? And they they earned their way into being
considered with everybody else. They they fought hard. They had
like jobs. They had this place in society. And then they were
incorporated in. They entered the halls of power and they they
everything kind of smoothed together, right?
You tell me like that's bad now because these people have like
slightly darker skin. That's the only difference
to figure out that we're American. But if you're saying if your
life depended on it, right? If let's say you played a game, right?
And your life depended on it. And you needed the person to guess
what you're trying to convey or else you die. And what you needed
to convey was an American, what would you draw? You would draw
a white a white individual with some overalls, cowboy hat, a
piece of wheat in their teeth, right? Maybe chewing some tobacco.
Hold on. What if you took all of those things and just made them
black? Would that suddenly become somebody else?
Like Myron's going to describe something, but if you drew them
black, would that make them something else? What if you drew
um like uh like
the what do you call it? Jumpman. What if he drew drunk man?
>> Is Michael Jordan American? Like there's no other country
that plays basketball anywhere near the same amount.
>> I don't know. >> Maybe a little drawer,
right? And an American flag cuz if your life depended on it,
that's what you would use. You would not use me, you would not
use you. You would not use a Muslim. Even though these people
can all be Americans, but there is a stereotypical image of what
an American is. Now, let's be honest, that is changing because
of mass immigration or whatever. But the reality is when you
think of an American, someone that hasn't been here before, that's
what comes to mind. country music, overalls, cowboy boots, >> and
anything not that should not be allowed. And it's asserting dominance.
>> I didn't say that it shouldn't be allowed. I said that
I think >> You said that they shouldn't be able to pray
in public. >> I think praying in public and disrupting
others. Disrupting others while praying in public. >> No
disrupted. No one's disrupted. >> Bro, you're disrupting.
You admitted it 20 minutes. Disruption. I think it's >> disrupting
what you What does that mean? What does that mean? >> Seiko
never admitted it. And also, you're allowed to have like what
do you call it? You're allowed to have gatherings in these places.
They got a permit. They're allowed to be there. People want to
go to Time Square. >> Like I I almost understand some people
complained about like riots and [__]
>> Oh, they didn't have a permit?
>> Oh, not cool. Sne
for mass public gatherings. I'm pretty sure you're supposed to.
Maybe not. Prayer might be protected in some way, but I still
think I still think you should get a permit. Never mind. Oh,
I lost part of my defense. Either way, I still think
the core of the argument is that
Myron believes Christians should be allowed to do that, right?
That like that's where the core of this argument is that like
church bells would not be disruptive. That kind of [__]
would not be disruptive, but for Muslims it would be.
So anyway, even if even if they didn't have a permit, it could
have been I guess like there could have been some congestion,
right? >> There were times where it wasn't closed. I agree
that you shouldn't be able to like shut down streets. >> If
like whenever you want. And just so you know, my haters, that's
what they're arguing with me. It's like we should be able to
shut down streets and do what we want to do. >> But that's
not what we did. You said that's what >> Not you. Not you.
But like >> No, but you said that's people in time. That's
not what happened. The the street was still open. The people
that were gathered there. Okay. But it's just >> there's
another thing too. They they've definitely shut down areas in
other places whether in the UK. >> I think there's like
some there's something to be said at a municipal level for gatherings.
But I again, if they if the city didn't come, if there wasn't
a complaint raised and the city didn't come and kick them out,
it's possible it didn't rise to that level, right? Like if you
want 20 friends to go do some kind of demonstration in Time Square,
that's almost certainly not a problem for anybody, right? You
want to go do like a a dance in Time Square and like record it.
I'm guessing that's not actually a problem for anybody. You're
not like disrupting anything. He said they were there for 20
minutes and it was done. Oh, I don't even know why they're using
this as an example then. This seems like totally fine. Freedom
of assembly. Well, hold on. And freedom of assembly does bow
to like some municipal rules, right? They're never going to I
like I don't think they're going to say you're you're getting
like um what do you call it? Like jailed or anything, but they're
going to say don't do that here. Like we'll find you under like
whatever municipality you're in.
>> Depending on if you're disrupting or not. And I think
it seems like there's no real argument that they were disrupting
actually. >> Uh playing playing that that multiple times
a day, playing it in Minneapolis, playing it in Dearborn, etc.
This is all disruptive to other Muslims. And I know you're saying,
"Oh, it wasn't a big We prayed in public like it was 20 minutes,
not a big deal, whatever. I still think that that is disrespectful
and rude because we know in a Muslim country a bunch of Christians
wouldn't be able to >> but you could do what you want in
public like that. Like I remember in 2011, remember you would
have I want to get 50 Christians and have them publicly gather
and they don't like that. Christians >> and pray in a symbolic
in a in a Muslim country in a symbolic area.
>> But those countries don't have the same
How Seiko I feel like Sneo's pointed this out, has he not? Because
it's it's definitely like the worst point Myron is making. Oh,
we would respect these countries. No, you would respect it because
one, it's like the it's essentially the law, right?
And two, it's like you could say that's a respectful thing and
you're doing it because you want to respect the the customs you
see, but the customs you see in America, the the values in America
are explicitly codified. >> You said they would get beheaded
if they did [clears throat] that. >> I was I was exaggerating,
but there would be problems. >> Oh, okay. Yeah. So it sounds
like it's codified there too that you have to act this way. But
why are you trying to take that approach and bring it to America?
>> The police would show up be like get the [__]
out of here. >> If they were if they were praying >> if
Christians showed up this is what Okay. If Christians showed
up let's say 50 Christians, right? What is the time square equivalent
in in uh >> also you said if they did that in Mecca then
they would be that was a ridiculous comparing time to Mecca.
>> Okay. Time square Mecca is not the same. I mean obviously
being hyperbolic and exaggerating but let's go ahead and give
a functional equivalent. >> Time square. Okay. React. say
uh >> Dubai actually know that that's not even I would
say the closest example to in the Middle East >> to Times
Square is like the Dubai Mall. >> No, no, that's not what's
symbolic. Um >> Times Square, >> let's say. Yeah.
>> The most commercial area in New York >> Yeah.
I'm trying to in the Middle East. Where would it >> Dubai
Mall? >> I Dubai Mall is not it, man. >> What What's
even close? >> If we if we took an area, let's let's say
maybe the Burj Khalifa or some [__] like that in
Dubai, UAE, right? >> That's not a commercial area. It's
a one building. That's one building. >> It's a tall skyscraper.
I don't know. The point I'm trying to make is >> okay.
50 Christians pray outside the Burj Khalifa. >> Yeah. If
if they prayed outside the Burj Khalifa out loud with speakers
and like that, I think the I think the police >> like hold
on.
What if the laws explicitly say they should be allowed to do
that?
It's not. There is no comparable because you have a codified
thing in America that says they should be allowed to do that.
You don't have that in uh Dubai. What is that? UAE, right? tell
them I can't imagine they have that definitely be like what what
are y'all doing? to say >> and they'd be like, "Yeah, yeah,
I got to go to a church." Like there would be they would not
be able to do >> there might be Oh, Sneo Sneo's uh in the
wrong direction here. Like he's he's probably thinking Muslims
are way more understanding. It's like not even that they're not
it's not that those people would be beheaded or something. It's
that it just wouldn't be accepted broadly, I think. Right.
It's not that but but the the core point he should make to rebut
this is okay. Yeah. But but in America, we have values. We have
a constitution that gives us the right to do this. Freedom of
religion, freedom of expression, freedom to gather, right? Make
our voices heard. This is all stuff we're allowed to do explicitly
under the law. There are not laws explicitly allowing this kind
of public gathering and public prayer for other religions in
any Muslim country as far as I know. Or maybe there are and I'm
just totally unaware, but I've never heard of it. And then I
think they've never heard of it either because they're not bringing
it up as the >> Do it as freely as you guys did in Time
Square is my point. They would not be able there. There would
be there would like you guys are actually >> would that
be a faith thing or because the UAE is a heavily much more heavily
policed than New York like >> well that goes to my my precise
point that you know it's a Muslim country and they're not standing
for that versus if you decided to pray they wouldn't bother >> If
50 Christian were standing there praying like this >> there
would be I and they made and they had loudspeakers all other
[__] there'd be a problem in the UAE there would
absolutely be a problem versus and they had loudspeakers and
they did what >> so your argument is that the US should
be more like the UAE. No, I'm saying that that what I'm saying
is that that level of tolerance is not acceptable in Muslim countries
and it's unfair for >> because they don't have freedom
of speech the same way we do. Like America is based off free
speech. That's why they can do that. >> It's not really
a faith thing. It's just a a principle thing. >> Well,
again, like I said before, we would that would not be tolerated
in a Muslim country, right? It would not be tolerated in a Muslim
country and we respect that >> because we they they have
because they have different rules. They don't have like the freedom
of speech doctrine in the same way we do. And what I'm saying
is since they since they don't have that there, we can't come
here and expect Oh, yeah. Well, we want to go ahead and do whatever
we want. You get what I'm saying? I'm talking about like the
Muslims that come [laughter] here. >> Yes. They keep saying
that, bro. I don't I'm not not American because I'm Muslim. Shut
the up. Stop saying I'm not >> You better want to do what
they want. >> Most people that came to talk are even Muslims
that are American. >> I was like most of the people there
were all born in America. Those >> of course of course.
But what I'm saying is that like that would not be allowed in
another Muslim country. So I look at it like it's fair. Like
if you can't do that, if if Christians can't go to a Muslim country
and openly pray the same way that Muslims do in the United States,
I think it just shows respect to not openly do it here. There's
more >> There's more Christians >> now just cuz you
can do it. >> My just doesn't understand that like this
is fundamentally these kinds of ideals are what made the US well
part of what made the US a powerhouse. Okay. Able to attract
talent from all over the
He's uh he's he's not understanding there's a secret sauce here.
There's a reason your countries are admiring despite having some
of the most resource value, most resource wealth on the planet.
All right. >> It doesn't mean you should. That's very important,
too. Just because you could doesn't mean you should >> pray
in public. >> Yeah. Just cuz you could, I don't think you
should. Especially as a guest, cuz you can go you could go to
your friend's house, right, and kind of now put your shoes on,
ask for extra food. >> Yeah, I know. But but I keep saying
this, but this is not my friend's house. This is my country.
>> See, that's that's that that's my country, man. >> That's
that entitlement Muslims, bro. This is why people don't like
Muslims, bro. Because it because I was born here. >> No,
no. Because they they have this mindset of like, oh, well, >> I'm
not a gu. But you think if people if people hate me because I'm
because I don't think like I'm a guest in my own country, then
they can hate me. >> But the faith is a the the the religion.
You are a guest. When you practice the religion, you are practicing.
>> It makes it makes me a guest to practice a different
religion. >> No, no, no. You're practicing a religion that
is not the moral fabric of this country. And you're doing it,
especially here's other thing. You're doing it openly when you
have access to do it privately. That's rude and disrespectful
to the host nation. Just because you could doesn't mean you should.
And that's the problem that a lot of these Muslim guys don't
get. Like >> praying is rude. >> No. Publicly and
disrupting others. Yes. >> I don't I don't buy. And also
you said >> And this is and this is why so many praying
will be the most submissive thing you could do. >> And
this is why people don't like Muslims because they have this
mindset of we're going to pray we want. >> Uh guys, this
is my last show for the night if we don't hit the goal. But it's
we're five subs away. All right. For another two hours on the
stream. Five subs away. $25. Get your TTS's in. Get your kicks
in. Get your subs in. All right. Just a short short chill here.
All right. We're just >> We're gonna do what we want to
do. We can't do nothing because this is a free country. Just
because it's a free >> that's why people hate Muslims.
>> Doesn't mean this is a big reason why they people hate
Muslims. I I think you actually I think you fell for the recent
propaganda. Like so right now, you know, people are getting paid
7K to push Israeli propaganda. I think it's I I think that that's
part of it is is making people >> Yeah, they're going to
make them hate >> Making people hate Muslims. Well, you
>> and and bro and this is why I'm saying these things
because I don't want cuz I know that they're going to push people.
I know they're going to push it. >> People hate Muslims
because of 15, 20, 30 years of propaganda because because of
of framing
>> some terrorist attacks, too. >> 911 and blaming
all Arabs for 911. They hate Muslims because of Israeli propaganda.
Not because of people praying. Not because I prayed in Time >> There
there were some bad things that happened. Okay, we could we could
there's a little bit of the propaganda. >> The hatred of
Muslims has nothing to do >> Here's the thing. Here's the
thing. 100 Dearborn is 100,000 people. It's a small city. Y >> like
this that the reason you're saying it's because some people prayed
in public when it's really due to the strongest propaganda machine
of all >> Absolutely. So, and I'm I love that you said
that. I understand as someone that worked in national security,
that worked in terrorism, etc., right? I understand this to a
deep degree that other people don't. The disdain for Muslims,
I agree with you. It cur it came from the war on terror. It came
from 9/11. It came from the propaganda and the lies that Israeli
neocons pushed, saying, "Muslims are the enemy. Muslims are the
enemy. Muslims are the enemy." I agree with you on that. What
I'm saying is we already have a bad rap. Unfortunately, in the
West, praying in public and disrupting people doesn't help our
cause.
Because I know because I know because I know how much they hate
us. >> My is the most individual on the planet Earth. This
is actually This is crazy. How do you, by the way, how do you
go in fresh fit, fresh and fit now as a woman and like take this
guy talking [__] to you, telling you you should be
submissive when he is the most submissive person on planet Earth?
He's doesn't consider himself an American. He doesn't think he
has the right to actual to actual free speech or freedom of expression
in his own country. Like, it's it's sad. It's sad that he's like
this much of a
I don't I don't know what he's trying to do. He's just sitting
here explaining to you how like he doesn't deserve anything close
to the level the standard of living of his white daddies right
now. He's like, "My white daddies should get everything. I shouldn't
get anything. I should take whatever they're willing to give
me, whatever scraps are left over. I should pray. I should be
silent. I should I should never pray outside. I should I should
always always kneel to the white daddies. Why?
What happened? What happened to this guy?"
>> And I know that the have been pushing this. I understand
it. That's why I'm saying, yo, they we already have a bad rap
here. Why are we going to go ahead >> they have a misunderstanding
about Islam. A lot of people think it's this crazy rel people.
So, the misunderstanding from the average
>> I'm sorry that I heard. He's like basically says, you
know what, Sneo, you convinced me. Muslims should be able to
pray in public and then he goes live and does like a cutie Cinderella
response to all the gropers. I'm sorry that what I said offended
people. I don't really handle social cues that well, guys. I'm
sorry. I'm sorry. >> American. They think a long walk bar
is a call for terrorism. And that really means God is the greatest.
So when people in Time Square see actually I I I I can tell you
from experience being there when they say like, "What are you
guys doing?" They're like, "Oh, we're praying because it's Ramadan."
They're like, "Oh, that's cool." When they when they learn what
it actually is, >> it's like it it changes their mind about
it. Cuz a lot of people have this idea that it's it's a violent,
oppressive, terrible religion. And they see like, "Oh, actually
we're not asserting dominance, but doing the most submissive
act, praying to God, putting your head on the floor." They're
like, "Oh, wow. Wait, this is" and they hear the Quran like,
"Oh, this is kind of peaceful. I kind of like it. It changes
their perception. It actually is da it. So everything else going
on time square is chaos, is drug deals, is the mo. It's just
stupid stupid stuff everywhere. And so these people, what are
you guys doing? They look over. I talked to people afterwards
like this is a time where we're fasting and prayer is extra important
right now. So we all got together to pray and they're like, "Oh,
it's kind of cool." >> Fair. Now I see your perspective.
But this is in New York City where people are liberal. They're
more open-minded. They want to learn. Fair. But you got to understand
that most of America isn't like that. Unfortunately, >> that's
why I think they used for the propaganda. People use that on
social media. I think these are 7K posts trying to like and they
put a caption like look at them taking over Time Square. It's
like no we didn't take over Time Square. We didn't disrupt anyone.
This is a section where we just prayed. I don't see that happening.
Here's the thing. I You take like an angled picture. They they've
swarmed Time Square. Muslims have invaded America. >> I
know that the propaganda is out there. So me and you have a different
way to deal with it. I'm saying the propaganda is out there.
Let's not make it worse. You're saying the propaganda is out
there. Let's change their mind. I'm saying they're not changing
their mind. They are though >> like we both agree.
Let's let's let's see where we agree. Here's a common ground.
We both agree that pushed out anti-Muslim propaganda for the
past 30 years. We agree 100%. I agree. >> And a lot of
Christians
many Christians at the same >> I I agree. They push out
that we're violent. They push out that we're heathens, that we're,
you know, brutes. We don't understand what we don't >> And
now we're guest on our own. >> I agree with you that they've
been pushing out this propaganda has been led by Neo. Agreed.
Now, your your your response to that is let's get them to understand
our religion and let's like we pray hopefully they'll be, you
know, open-minded and they'll want to learn. Cool. Some people
will. My argument is I think most people won't. And I think given
the propaganda has been pushed in America for so goddamn long
that these have been pushing saying Islam is bad. Islam is bad.
These guys are jihadists. They want to kill everybody, etc. It's
not just you saying that. It's like it's a lot of stupid Christians
that evangelical Christians believed it as well. You're right.
They've been pushing it. This is what this guy's got to pick
a lane. Either Christians are your white daddies or you hate
or you or you hate evangelicals. You can't do both at the same
time. Okay? You can't be a gas. You can't defer to Christians
all the time. And they go evangelicals are totally the biggest
voting block, the biggest conservative Christian voting block
that >> This is what a lot of Americans think. So when
we openly pray, when we do these things, what do they assume?
They assume that we're trying to assert dominance and we're trying
to take the country over. And then you have other Muslims saying
we're going to spread Islam all across the place with this propaganda.
Again, it's propaganda. I agree with you is propaganda. My argument
to this push by the propaganda is we need to be measured and
understand that we need to operate in a way where people don't
understand the religion and most people don't care to understand
the religion. You're operating from a position of yo, they want
to understand, they should understand. That's the good way that
I I that's bro, if people wanted to understand the religion,
>> but I'm not going to play into the rage bait. Like I'm
not going to let that win. I'm saying most Americans don't care
and they don't want to understand. >> I don't I don't find
that to be true. I think that this is an echo chamber on Twitter.
I think that this is due to propaganda posts and most normal
people don't think the way that you see on the like a small minority
on online. >> I'm I'm telling you, bro. I'm telling you,
it's a silent majority of people that do not like Islam and they
don't they don't trust Muslims. They look at us like we're wild
and we're going to take over and I think that us praying outside
exacerbates the problem. And there's other ways to go about like
changing the narrative is not, you know, >> making himself
small, submissive, breedable, so cool, >> more submissive
and like acting more like a guest and [laughter] abiding by the
lies and operating around that. >> Sneo just called him
submissive. I did not think Sneo would say the word that is so
obviously right there that >> it's showing the truth and
and being >> Sneo just called Myron submissive. By the
way, I don't know how Myron Can I look back? What was his facial?
>> Changing the narrative is not, you know, being more
submissive and like acting more like a guest and abiding by the
lies and operating around that. It's showing the truth and and
being comfortable who you are. >> I think it's
operating on the reality of where we stand as a nation where
people >> cowering is not the way to change it. >> It's
not about cowering. It's about >> in private like, "Oh,
I can only pray in private because I don't want I don't want
the people who hate me to hate me >> See, you're going
extreme. I'm not saying it's about private. >> You said
you should pray in private so that people who hate you don't
hate me. >> Pray go to the mosque. Pray at your house like
privately. >> Yeah. So you're saying pray privately so
people hate me don't hate me more. >> Bro, we have a bad
reputation. Do you think exacerbating the problem and praying
out in public and blocking off streets and doing all this is
the way to go? I don't think so. I don't think so. I think that
makes >> I think that I think that makes people hate us
even more. >> Operating in fear. >> Uh okay. I think
if if you believe this
>> one you you have like two options. Convert to Christianity
or leave the country. Right. If you believe this is the case,
why would you leave this? Why would you live this eternally existence
within your own country if you think that you never will have
the right to be like out in public with your religion, right?
You'll never have any of these rights. Then just go go to like
a Muslim country and live there. Bro, what are you what are you
doing? >> Fear because of lies is not the way to >> it's
not about operating in fear. It's about operating with respect.
Operating in reality, operating >> but you don't have any
respect. Why live in a country where you'll never get respect?
If you live your beliefs, you'll never be entitled to respect.
Why wouldn't you try to change your country? Especially if your
country has a value that is its values should be able to >> Yeah.
Most people don't care about >> Most most people don't
care about Muslims and don't care to learn, bro. Like let's be
honest. When they say, "Oh, O, you don't understand Judaism properly."
And they try to sit there and tell you, "Let me tell you about
Judaism." You're like, "You like I don't give a [__]
about you." Don't sit there and try to have your rabbi come in
cuz we used to on for trying to tell people, "Well, you're being
anti-semitic." Same exact thing with Islamophobia. These [__]
don't care about our religion. They don't give a [__]
about learning about it. We're the minority and they look at
us as invaders. That's the reality. They look at us as invaders.
>> I I think it's just a really close-minded way to see
people. I'll give you an example. >> I agree. It's closeminded,
but that's the reality. >> It was Yamapur. >> That's
the reality. >> Yamapour was like 2 weeks ago in New York.
I was biking through uh downtown Manhattan and it was Yamapur.
We go through a park. >> They shut down everything in Brooklyn.
It's ridiculous. >> Yeah, they shut it down. And I was
biking through a park and I see a large gathering of people and
I'm vlogging. I'm like, "What's this?" I pull up to the vlog
um to film and I hear them. It's like, "Oh, the these are celebrating
Yamapoor." And I listen up. I'm like, "Okay." And then I hear
the speech a little bit because I'm curious what they're saying.
They were all leftist criticizing Israel. The rabbi at the front
of the speech was saying they were saying they weren't acidic.
They were
this is I like this comparison. I don't know. I don't know how
I feel about it for sure. But it is kind of the same thing of
like uh this thing that like I think is actually principally
important is I'm going to say that we shouldn't make any noise
about it because right now that could go like badly for us possibly
in the future if we make noise and try to follow the principles.
So, I think we should like couch our principles and and hide
them and pretend we don't have them. And then maybe later we
could do something. And it's like this infinite it's like the
infinite works that happen that you'll you'll just never ever
move forward at that point. Do you think do you think if if black
people were like, "Hey, it's just not the right time to try to
break these chains." Do you think that ever would have happened?
Right? Like it's at some point at some point you have to stand
up for what you think is right. What if white people thought
about that? What if white people thought that way? Oh, it's just
not quite the right time to help these people break the bonds
of slavery to stop cattle slavery. Like it's it's just not the
right. You should just live your principles. And I can't imagine
living in a country where we're expressing your principles. Not
even living them, but expressing them. And if they don't jive
with the country, you think, hey, my country is actually wrong
on this. I can't imagine living somewhere where I wouldn't where
I would where it would be penalized where like you would it would
be a crime for you to say so.
What if you want transports? You should be allowed to say it,
man. They look like normal. The rabbi said >> it's usually
the super religious ones that are critical of Israel. >> In
the speech, he said have been refugees for so long. How could
the state of Israel do the same thing that happened to us? We've
been kicked out of so many countries. How are we now expelling
Palestinian? >> You said you did say secular. >> How
are Palestinians expelling people from their own home? And I
listened. I was like, "Oh, this is this guy's based." And I like
kind of joined. I listened for a while. And I was pleasantly
surprised. I would not have known that so many people did that
if they weren't doing it publicly. You know, maybe if you go
online, this is >> Oh, Sneo Sneo dropping some grass touching
red pills. Okay. Oh, I went and talked to I went and listen to
these. They're actually like kind of supporting the Palestinians
a little bit and I didn't realize
he's literally describing how people become like not racist.
He's literally describing like positive interactions with another
ethnic group, religious group, whatever the that they like go
positively or unexpectedly positively and then it's like, "Oh,
I had like the wrong picture of these people." It suddenly humanizes
them.
>> A great analogy. By the way, if you're online all the
time and you see, you know, a certain amount of information,
you're going to have a certain view of like Muslims or Christians.
So, Twitter will have you think one way about, you know, and
I was I saw that. I was like, you know, I came in with the stereotype
and then I listened to what they're saying and I learned something
that I didn't know before. I talked to some of the people there
and then I I went about my day. >> But see, Sneo, you're
assuming that everyone is going to be uh inquisitive and an open-minded
individual. >> That's such a good example. Like because
I'm seeing the Twitter, you know, atmosphere where people are
like, "Oh,
>> and so and they're like one of the >> and I assumed
that was going to be like a pro Israel thing." >> One of
the one of the biggest mistakes people make, bro, is assuming
that other people have the intellect that they do. The re the
reality, bro, is that most people and they're low IQ and they're
not going to care to learn or understand anything. How do you
how do you say most people are low IQ
while doing this while like getting literally every point you
make? I don't know. I don't even know how Sneaker is going to
do it yet. I haven't thought about his argument Myron just made
that like too many people are dumb. This seems to be like appealing
to the lowest common denominator. This is very hutchpilled. like,
hey, people aren't smart enough to like hear what like the good
ideas are, so we should like hide those good ideas and then we'll
like we'll get them on our side and then we'll bring out the
good ideas later once we have like control. It's like, aren't
you describing like lying about your beliefs to get elected and
then doing something totally different? Like, what the [__]
What? What? Huh?
I don't What are we doing here? Because Trump does it. You could
say because Trump does it, but like if you can't go another way,
if there's no paradigm shift, then you're just buying into populism
yourself. You just you're just saying, "Okay, we're going lowest
common denominator and Trump won." Trump won. Russia won. China
won. Every other country that's not the United States won. Okay.
>> Thing they're going to be like, "Yo, I have my world
view."
>> Wait, Madison, that's fine. I just I don't think it
would be wrong for I think it would be wrong for Obama to lie
about being against gay marriage and then to publicly repeatedly
advocate for gay marriage to be passed. Right. I And as far as
I know, that's not what he did. He was pretty mum on the issue
for a very long time. Right. I think if you're going to run on
a position that's the position you should you got elected on,
you should be running on that or so you should be trying to get
that whatever you've run on pushed through uh by virtue of being
elected on it. Right? If you run on some position for an election,
you should try to maintain it unless there's tangible evidence,
tangible things that have changed. I don't understand what could
possibly change your view of gay marriage. He said his views
were uh evolving. Okay.
Yeah, I I would just imagine if Obama was putting pressure on
people to get gay marriage passed, if he was on a bully pulpit
pushing for gay marriage, I'd be like, "Oh, that seems kind of
wrong given that you said you were against it to get elected."
And I don't think I don't think that's a weird thing to say.
You can you can not talk about certain things. You could take
certain positions, right, that aren't like uh aren't exactly
what you believe, but then you shouldn't be saying like later
we're going to break out the good ideas. That shouldn't be how
you act. >> Changing or whatever. And what I'm saying is
for 30 years they've been pushing this propaganda that Muslims
are violent. We want to take over. We want to do XYZ. Even though
it's not true and I agree with you. >> How is my analogy
not the perfect example? Like >> because most people are
not going to be like you and be open-minded and stop doing what
they're doing to learn and be like, "Damn, this is different."
>> But if but if it's publicly and they hear it, then yeah,
they will then have their choice to be openminded. >> A
lot of people will not be openminded is what I'm trying to say.
They won't stop. You're you're you're hoping that the common
lowest common denominator of person is going to be on your level.
I'm telling you, >> I don't feel like appealing to the
lowest common denominator of people. >> That's the majority.
Unfortunately, that's the majority and that's why I'm trying
to tell you like don't give a about Islam and they're not going
to learn. They're not going to care to figure it out. >> I
mean, walking on eggshells, walking walking on eggshells so stupid
people
remain stupid is just like >> it's not walking on eggshells.
It's it's understanding that you're a guest here and respecting
that and then praying like where you have can. Dude, even Christians
don't shut down streets and do all this [__] >> There's
Christian festivals when they >> And even if they did and
even if they did, this is their country in in a Muslim country.
UAE, whatever. You could do that cuz it's their country. This
is not our country. This is not our >> You can't I mean,
look, there's more Christians in Saudi Arabia than there are
Muslims in America. There's more like people have this uh misconception.
They all the time say America is a Christian country. Like in
the Middle East, like Morocco, there's public churches everywhere.
People pray. I went to Lebanon recently. There were so many Christians
and people actually there's big statues of Mary. Yeah. People
say perfect. They said Lebanon is a Muslim country. You go there,
there's a giant statue of Jesus. That's publicity.
>> Maradoo, thank you for the gifted sub. Let's go. >> It's
half Christian. But bro, again, >> people should be able
to exercise their faith publicly. Like, it's not >> Look,
I think if you're a minority, especially a a small minority,
like a 1 or 2%, I think you need to understand where you kind
of stand. >> So, the Christians in Lebanon can't pray in
public. >> Well, they're like 50%, bro. They're like 50%.
>> It's not It's not They're so minority. It's like it's
it's 40% or something. So, technically, by your logic, they're
>> By your logic, they should take down the Jesus statue
in Lebanon. It's like one of the big monuments of the country.
Well, again, they're a huge portion of the country. They're damn
near half. That's a bit different. Now, >> so minority
is less than it's less than >> 2% versus we got like >> 2%
versus 49% is a big difference, bro. Like a minority at 2% is
not the same as a minority at 49%. Like, you do have a voice
there to a degree. >> Still a minority. I'm just following
your logic. But, but again, it's it's uh like I said before,
I do think >> No, I'm just I'm just following what you're
saying, Myron. We both know what the definition is. You could
say you could make a different differentiation now, but then
you're just saying that so so my then once what's your percentage
right that's where should go what's your percentage where you
can like actually start you know doing things out in
cuz then the argument would be well once Muslims become this
percentage of the population then it's fine right doesn't matter
what the original founding stock was can't make that argument
anymore >> that as Muslims we are guests here this is not
a Muslim country >> I have a feeling that if you ask if
you ask my like hey through some miracle people are enlightened.
40% of Americans transition immediately overnight to Islam. It's
not quite there, but it becomes like basically like Lebanon.
Now, can they pray outside?
I have a feeling he would still say no >> country. I think
we can agree on that. You think that >> the founding you
keep saying this like the founding fathers think it's a Christian
country. >> According to the founding fathers, I'm not
a guest here. >> Well, again, the founding >> you
maybe, but I mean I'm literally following the logic that was
outlined. the following fathers. >> That might make them
the slight plurality, but I'm saying whatever would make them
like a a very slight minority in the country. >> Again,
I think >> they said it's for all. They said freedom of
religion. They said freedom of speech. I'm going to follow their
>> Yeah. When when they when they framed that in mind,
they didn't think we would have, you know, Muslims praying openly
in areas and disrupting people. I don't >> Thomas Jefferson
had a copy of the Quran and he specified that Muhammad should
be able to practice a religion. >> Of course, but they
never they never specified. No, it's not. Yeah, >> but
they didn't say they didn't say >> practicing a religion
is not the same as practicing a religion overtly and disrupting
others. Again, bro, I'm my I'm only saying I don't think that
we should be practicing our religion at the detriment to others
enjoying their >> No, nobody was there was nobody was no
one's liberties were inflicted on, >> bro. Like when you're
playing the adan multiple times a day in in in US cities. >> Okay,
so if you're playing loud music in a car, which happens all the
time and they go to they they get a ticket for that. They get
>> You don't get a ticket for that in New >> You're
playing loud music. You don't get a ticket for that in New York.
>> There's there's or
everyone in Brooklyn has a giant >> That's the problem.
We don't want to hear that dumbass rea. We don't want to hear
that. >> Yeah. But not even that. What about rap >> This
is why New York City is dysfunctional. That's precisely the problem
that like these idiots come in and they bring their
>> Dude,
I want to go to New York City at some point and meet Sneo. I
want to just meet him on the side of the road. I want to show
up. That's actually You guys don't even know this, okay? My face
reveal is actually going to be in a two-minute podcast clip,
okay? You guys will never know it. I'll go I'll go talk to Sneo.
We'll have a great conversation.
That'll come out and then I'll be able to like, you know, 6 months
maybe maybe it's already happened, but 6 months, 12 months, 2
years later. All right. I'm going to go look that was me. That
was me. I was there the whole time.
>> That's a problem. >> Okay. What about the giant
screens in Tascar? Are they not disrupting people's >> Oh,
come on, man. Now, what do you mean? Come on. You're talking
about You're talking about the audio the audio >> This
is not the same as >> How is that not the same? >> Okay.
comparing a minority religion and practicing it in a uh tourist
hotspot in the United States is not the same as running a video
or an ad on the TV which is a part of capitalism which is a fabric
of this country and people paying to have that >> capitalism
is fabric of the country but freedom of religion isn't >> freedom
of yes but what we're we're not talking about freedom of religion
anymore we're talking about openly practicing your religion uh
and disrupting others I'm not saying people Muslims can't practice
bro I'm not saying that like I'm saying I don't think it's appropriate
as a minority religion to be openly practicing your religion
and disrupting others because it is disruptive. Even even if
it might be disruptive a little bit 20 minutes >> Do you
think it would be appropriate? Let's start taking other constitutional
protections away. Do you think it would be appropriate okay my
for you to own a gun? Sorry. Oh, how would this even work? I'm
trying to think of the exact confound here. The the confounding
question here. Like, do you think it would be inappropriate for
you, Myin, to execute or to exercise any of your other constitutionally
protected
rights? Would you fail to
Would would you not do that because it makes people uncomfortable?
Listen, you're Muslim. Don't you think because you're Muslim,
it might make people a little uncomfortable if you own guns?
Like, should you be allowed to own an AK-47 as a Muslim person
living in America? Wouldn't that make your white daddies like
kind of uncomfy?
Should Myron be allowed to buy fertilizer? Yeah. Like should
we really should he be allowed to get a pressure cooker? I think
I would feel more comfortable if my as a Muslim man was not allowed
to buy a pressure cooker in America. That's just me personally,
you
That's it. Own guns but can't take it outside of the house. There's
like a whole bunch of other things like what other things do
you have to give up to be a guest, a quote unquote guest in the
>> Here maybe 5 seconds here with the Adan or whatever.
It is disruptive and I don't think as a 2% population we should
be doing that because we wouldn't do we wouldn't stay a minority.
Don't say a small minority in private power and be >> but
it's we're always going to be a minorities in America. >> So
So just hide in fear. >> No, go to a Muslim country if
you want that. You have bro there's here's the thing. UAE, Qatar,
Kuwait, these countries are safer, cleaner, no taxes in some
case more financially advantageous than America.
Why are you Sneo? Please ask him why he's in America. Like just
ask why he's in America. That he's laid out the entire case for
why he should get the out. What is he doing there? Go to the
UAE. No taxes. And they love expatriots. >> I like America.
>> Fine. I think if you're And I think it's it's important
to assimilate if you're going to be in America. And assimilating
and assimilation is >> is what? Go to Times Square. And
so what what am I supposed to do in Time Square to assimilate?
>> Uh be quiet. Take your pictures. >> Time Square
is the opposite of quiet. >> Well, everyone's loud in Time
Square. >> But don't be disruptive. And >> what what
about the dancers in Time >> Those are annoying. >> That's
part of time like literally every time you go to Time Square
are annoying. >> There's the same the the circles, the
crowds that gather. Bro, nobody wants to watch these ginu forc.
>> Yeah, they do. People all the toys go and gather [laughter]
up there. And that takes the same amount of space as the prayer
did. Are they disrupting? Are they not allowed to do that?
>> Getting in the way. Get a permit. Pay for it. Like like
>> you don't need a permit for a sidewalk. That's the point.
>> No, you do actually >> to dance on a sidewalk.
No, you don't. >> You actually do need a permit. If I when
I set up my table and I want to do the debates, I got to get
a permit even though it's on a public sidewalk. >> Yeah.
For the dance the dancers, they don't need permits. They never
have. >> Well, they just don't get them. And your NYPD
doesn't want to enforce that. >> What law says you need
to get a permit to dance, >> bro? You if you're gonna block
off an area, right? >> You're not blocking off. A crowd
randomly like gathers on its own. >> Yeah. But you're disrupting
the walkway for everybody else. You need a permit, >> But
that's
really open specifically for that so people can, you know, gather.
>> Yeah, that's what we're saying is my basically thinks
you should give up a bunch of constitutional rights
because you're like a minority in the country, minority religion,
minority ethnicity, I guess. And then and then not only does
he think that, he also thinks apparently
that he wants to live in America. I don't understand why he has
not given a single case for why he should be able to why he should
still be in America. He just gave all the positive cases to move
to Qar. My why don't you just move to Qar then? Go to Qar
and do what they want. Yeah. No, no, no. It's not. That's why
you have to get a permit. Like literally, bro, I have to deal
with this with the city of Miami. New York City is even worse
with that. It's just that these guys do it and NYP don't really
do [__] cuz like bro, like I'm not going to waste
my time and the paperwork. site doesn't offer, you know, not
getting a permit, but they should be getting a >> So, it's
it's illegal for them to what >> Okay. So, setting up some
type of performance or, you know, whatever the [__]
it may be where, you know, that you're going to create a crowd
or whatever and they're doing it to geners are literally >> and
they're doing it and it's a commercial act. They're doing it
to make money. This is why you need a per permit. But, but again,
New York is filled with lip tards and this is why New York City
sucks. This is why no one likes New York City. As a matter of
fact, you love New York City. I hate New York City. So, like
criminals, degenerates, too much multiculturalism. you got these
that don't want to speak English. Like this is why New York City
sucks. I think the multiculturalism that you like that is precisely
why New York City is in the I I think that's why it's so so bad
because of all the multiculturalism. And I think you know I >> you
hate multiculturalism.
>> I I think it creates a lot of problems. I do think so
because people don't want to assimilate, right? Like where there's
blocking off areas in in just so you know, I don't like Puerto
Rican day parades. I don't like the Caribbean day parades. These
these degenerate like shaking their asses and [__]
This is a big reason why like I don't uh why I had to leave the
Northeast because like these Puerto Rican day parades and these
Dominican day parades >> dude there's way more Dominicans
and Puerto Ricans in Miami than there are >> no no we don't
have as many here. >> Okay. Venezuelans
whatever but them aren't as ostentatious as Puerto Ricans and
Dominicans. They have to have their parades and do their and
play their regular and it's annoying bro. It's it's disturbing.
It's annoying. Like we don't want that [__]
>> hold on hold on. Uh BB Poison he's actually from Brooklyn.
I thought he was Sudanese too but he's actually from >> Oh
yeah. Um, but anyway, born inrooklyn,
you think America hates you? >> No. No. I don't think America
hates me. I just think that, you know, as guests, we should respect
the um [laughter] we should respect the country that we're a
part of. >> You're not You're not a guest, bro. >> we
we are guests, man. >> We are guests, bro. We are like,
we're first generation Americans. Well, maybe you might be second
or third generation. >> I'm first. Yeah. >> Yeah.
So, you're first Okay. So, bro, we're visitors here, bro. Like,
we're guests here. Like, I know you don't like hearing that.
>> Um, yeah. My mom was born here and my dad moved here.
That makes me born. >> Okay. So you're somewhat first >> Yeah.
One and a half. >> Okay. One and a half. I I think honestly,
bro, >> by definition, I'm not a guest. My >> just
as much as whoever hates whoever hates me and thinks that I'm
not a guess, they can like they can choke because like just based
off that I'm I'm just as American as you. Being an American is
not defined by your race. It's not defined by your religion.
It's defined by the tenants of what it means and what they wrote
down with the found what the founding fathers wrote. And it's
also defined by your passport and your birth certificate. >> And
that that ambiguity is the problem. It's not it's not ambiguous
at all. >> That ambiguity with like not saying like an
American is anything that is >> then blame the founding
fathers cuz that's what they wrote. >> They didn't intend
that anyone who they didn't intend that these immigration laws
like everything up. They did not intend it for it to become this
way where we're just importing people from all over the world
to come here. Like that ambiguity is what creates the problems
because these people come from these other countries with their
up culture with their up practices and they try to bring it here
and then this is where you run into multiculturalism and you
run into problems. Bro, me and you live in in Well, we're here
in Bickl, so
>> It's it's multicultural here. >> You're more Spanish
here than English. >> True. But well, there's there's also
a lot of Jews here, too. Um than Hispanics, but these are like
cream of the crop. These are like people that are royalty in
their countries wherever they go. But let's be honest, the safest
neighborhoods in America, what are they? >> they're white
majorities typically. >> Right. Like like that that's where
we're going to be at. Like so. >> Yeah. But the cultural
center of the world is New York City and that's because of multiculturalism
>> and New York City sucks. >> Yeah. That that's
where all the great art comes. >> Why? Why
>> isn't it like the highest GDP like the highest output
wealth city in the world? I don't know. Everything >> Why
does it suck? Cuz you you don't like hearing about crime on the
subway. Is that it? >> That's where everything starts.
New York City is like the >> There's a lot of gay people
there. Okay. >> Center of the universe. Exactly. Because
of multiculturalism. Because people come there from all over
the world. Because people put their best out there. Like I
I just don't see by what standard does New York City suck? I
feel like you could maybe go to Japan and argue that those metropolises
are like better better managed than by what metric does New York
City suck? Like
like go to any major metropolis in like another city and it's
going to suck way harder than New York City, right?
I don't know. I Dude, >> there's going to be crime and
>> he's not even giving reasons. He's literally not giving
reasons beyond like I guess he said crime sne just refuted that
said crime's down like lower than it's basically been in in decades
>> places but that's where you get greatness. If you want
quiet suburbs with nothing going on then sure go >> But
I I think that multiculturalism is actually what's led New York
City to the problems that it has now. >> Every city has
pro every city has crime and problems. >> Yeah, of course.
But like New York City is like that's supposed to be our beacon
city. Well, like why is it that New York City and Yeah, but like
why why is it that New York City is so terrible, right? Well,
you know what? Let's go ahead and have this discussion. Why is
that New York City is is so trash with the multiculturalism,
but you go to the UAE, they have a lot of multiculturalism, but
why is it wh why why is it >> because they don't have freedom
of speech and they don't have they don't have the same like freedoms
that Americans have >> and they have very they got an aparttheid
state basically. >> If you're a foreigner and you commit
a >> so you want to change the definition like you literally
want to change everything. What being an American? >> No,
I'm just saying. >> Yeah. He wants to He wants it to be
like [__] He wants it to be like an Arab >> We
do multiculturalism wrong is what I'm saying. We do it here in
America wrong versus in UAE. They >> tell the then tell
the founding fathers they up then say being an American that
what they did is wrong. >> I I didn't Well, here's the
thing. It's not what they did is wrong. It's just that they didn't
expect for this.
They made a mistake. >> Lyndon B. Johnson to like sign
the Civil Rights Act and bring everybody. >> So, you're
saying the founding fathers [__] up? >> No,
I'm not saying they [__] up, but they didn't foresee
this stuff. 400. >> That's making a mistake.
Wait, who whose fault is 911? Wait, did the did the government
up with 911? Well, I wouldn't say they up. They just didn't foresee
certain things happening. >> They didn't foresee. They
did not foresee what would happen in 19 in the in the 60s with
uh Lynon B. Johnson and >> What happened? You know, do
you think I [__] up by rear ending your car, Myin,
with my truck? No. You just didn't foresee that like I would
stop as suddenly as I did. He's literally just describing a [__]
like directly. >> No, it's like that. They did not foresee
that. They they did not foresee what would we we be now. And
and I and I truly do think if they knew that it was going to
be like this. I don't think they they would have probably put
some measures in there like yeah, we got to limit immigration
to this. We got to maintain a certain percentage of people to
this and everything else like that. I think they would have probably
serious if they knew the future was coming that we have now,
they would have absolutely adjusted things >> in the founding
documents differently. >> Oh, the founding fathers made
a mistake. I don't think they were wrong. I I think that they
didn't foresee a lot of this [__] which is fair.
I mean, no one can foresee 400 years in advance, three 400 years,
like all this [__] >> right? That like I I
don't think they foraw that this would this [__]
would >> Yeah. But I mean, bottom line, I >> still
think we're the greatest country in the world. Don't get it twisted.
I just think like when it comes to the whole Well, the freedoms
we have, the Hold on. The freedom we have. Hold [laughter] on,
hold on, hold on. >> Exactly. So, I'm going to pray in
public cuz that's my freedom. >> The main reason I was
I was going to say mostly the capitalistic opportunities here.
We first thing you said was >> Well, I was going to get
into >> the freedoms to pray in public. You're not going
to let me know the freedoms to pursue the to pursue uh wealth
creation in any way that you want. >> Wealth creation.
>> Yes. Like capital. Why do you think people come to people
come to America to make money? This we are the land of opportunity.
So like we have a bunch of capitalistic opportunities that other
countries simply don't. That's what makes us the best country.
>> We have freedom. Could you not have done the Fresh and
Fit? Like literally the only thing he's describing is the trafficking
that happens via the Fresh and Fit podcast, right? Like that's
that's the only opportunity he has via America. Otherwise, he
could do every other aspect of his life just as easily in an
Arab country.
There's like literally he described why Qar would be better for
him.
Qatar just doesn't have a bunch of women who would fly out to
his podcast to be on it and get called. >> There's other
countries you get freedom at. UK is a fairly free society, too.
I agree. I agree with your first point. I I agree with you. You
cut me up, man. >> The freedom is what makes us great.
I'm about to go pray in the middle of brick right now. Capitalism.
>> I'm about to go shut down the street. >> All right.
You got to go. >> All Muslims, let's go right now. Lawbar.
>> Yes. He's going to pray on the street, guys. Where you
going to shut us down? >> This is my home. I own this country.
I'm not going anywhere on Where you going to Which street you
going to shut down? >> I'm going to I'm going to shut you
down. >> Suddenly got based out of nowhere >> here
on on First A. I'm going to be blasting the Quran. All Muslims
are going to pull through. No one's going to be able to walk.
Thanks for having me >> Yeah. No, no, it's good, man. and
thank you for staying. I I know. >> Welcome to the party,
man. I'm so glad you're happy uh you're you're here on party
man.
>> Yeah, I'm sorry for uh for holding you here longer than
I told you I would.
>> Damn, what a debate. That's crazy, chat. All right,
that's crazy. See what else we got on the docket for tonight.
I think we um What do we got here?
We had the Darius stuff. There's going to be more going on. All
right, there's going to be more going on. I think I'm going to
peace out. All right, there's five minutes left, but it's like
it's five minutes. All right, so I'm gonna peace out and I'll
be back tomorrow.
So, we will see all of you guys tomorrow. I'll do the Darius
stuff tomorrow. There's like more stuff to add. So,
Uh there's more stuff to add to that, so we can we can get it
all in tomorrow. Okay, I'll be back. Have a good night, guys.
See you later. Bye-bye.